So.
Da bin ich.
Ach, du Kacke.
Bisschen groß.
Alter, da drehst du ja motion sick.
Alter, da drehst du ja...
Oh, da wird es dir ja schlecht bei.
Da wird es dir ja schlecht bei, Alter.
Genau so, genau so, ey.
Fuck.
Ah.
Wie macht man das wieder aus?
Ah, exzellent.
Ich dachte, das klingt immer aus, ey.
Das wäre schlecht gewesen, ey.
Monk KS.
Kacke Triple U.
Ich muss übrigens mein Tool neu starten.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Aha, so.
Äh, jetzt aber.
Exzellent.
Oh, Michael 50 Billiarden.
Das ist auch mal wieder...
Michael, hast du eine 0 weniger als sonst?
Kann das sein?
0 verloren.
Was haben wir hier?
Also, Chat.
Chill im Eck, sagt...
Direkt eine Frage.
Wenn du CPU-Temperatur-ETC auslesen willst
und dir eine kleine Anzeige dafür basteln willst,
welche Sprache und Framework würdest du dafür verwenden?
Äh, chill im Eck.
Die Frage ist,
willst du irgendeine Hardware haben mit einer Anzeige
oder willst du auf dem Desktop ein Programm haben,
was was anzeigt?
Das ist die Preisfrage jetzt dabei.
Auf dem Desktop will ich das machen.
Ja, das ist überhaupt...
Kein Problem.
Also, wenn du es auf dem Desktop machen willst.
Ich habe schon gedacht, weil in Hardware ist es deutlich interessanter zu machen als auf dem Desktop, ja.
Ähm, ich muss mal kurz übrigens in den Chat refreshen, weil da gerade nichts anzeigt.
Ähm...
Also, du willst das ja wahrscheinlich selbst programmieren, gehe ich mal von aus.
Also, du willst ja im Endeffekt einfach nur eine Zahl anzeigen.
Dann kannst du irgendeine Windows-Forms-Anwendung machen.
Wie du richtig CPU...
Ähm...
Richtig CPU-Temperatur ausliest,
das kann ich dir aber nicht sagen.
Wie man das macht, das müsste ich nachgucken.
Das ist irgendeine Windows, ähm...
WPMI, ne, wie heißt...
WMI, ähm...
CPU-Temperatur-Windows-WMI?
Heißt das WMI?
Ja.
Damit kannst du das wahrscheinlich auslesen.
Oder aber mit den passenden Flags von der CPU.
Das ist dann aber herstellerabhängig.
Das weiß ich aber nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht aus dem Kopf.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, mal im Stream schon gemacht.
CPU-Temperatur ausgelesen, ne?
Taser!
Nice, dankeschön.
Excellent subscription.
Und eigentlich schon für die ganzen Subs hier.
Aber wenn du einfach nur ein Display haben willst, was was anzeigt,
mach dir einfach ein stinknormales Windows-Forms.
Ja.
Oder wenn du es transparent machen willst, würde ich es mit WPF machen.
Weil WPF deutlich besser mit Transparenz funktioniert.
Ja.
Ist wunderbar, dass Sie es haben.
Aber das Tech-Sоюzer.
Wem nicht, der anticipiert natürlich sein Business mit Windows.
Wenn manai!
Der überrascht mich sehr.
Ich freue mich, dass er auch jetzt ein neues Textspiel rauskommt.
Ich mag es ganz schön.
Das war es für heute.
Wir sehen uns wieder beim nächsten Video.
Bis dann!
Ja, und ja!
Auf Wiedersehen.
Bis bald!
Ciao, ciao!
Ciao, ciao, ciao!
Wartet mal, Windows Logo, das muss ich jetzt mal schnell ausprobieren.
Windows Logo als GIF, ist das schon ein GIF?
Das ist ein GIF, passt mal auf Leute, jetzt kommt Big Brain.
Windows Logo, Havakek W als Emote irgendwo, perfekt.
Also, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Doch, OVP ist neuer, allerdings kann man mit OVP nichts anfangen.
Wenn du ne OVP Anwendung machen willst, musst du die mit nem Zertifikat signieren und das kostet 3 Euro im Jahr.
Oder du verteilst über den Windows Store.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert, was ich mir hier vorstelle.
Wartet mal kurz.
Desktop, wo haben wir das Windows Logo?
Windows Logo, wo ist das Windows Logo? Ich hab's doch grad.
Windows Logo?
Alter, wohin hab ich jetzt das Windows Logo gedownloadet?
Ja, so.
Windows Logo?
Ah, Windows Logo, Havakek W, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Havakek W, so, das machen wir jetzt mal alles ein bisschen kleiner hier.
Achtung, hab ich sie kleiner.
So, so, okay, okay, mal gucken, passt, passt mal auf.
Big Brain, hoch, ha, geht das nicht?
Hab ich das jetzt falsch rum gemacht?
Ha, das geht nicht, wie ich mir das vorgestellt hab.
Ich wollte das hier eigentlich als Maske verwenden, dass ich Kek, Kek, W auf, auf, ähm, hm, geht das vielleicht so?
Ah, alter Leute, ich bin zu dumm für Bildbearbeitung.
Ich bin, ich bin, ich bin für Bildbearbeitung einfach zu dumm.
Ich bin für Bildbearbeitung einfach zu blöd, äh.
Ich will das klippen, ich will das klippen auf das Windows Logo.
Das muss doch gehen.
Ich bin, ich bin, ey, ohne Scheiß.
Was Bildbearbeitung angeht, bin ich einfach zu dumm für.
Was, was, Steuerung, und dann?
True Morpheus, alter, ich hab's gesehen.
Passt, ey, ja, passt, passt mal auf, Leute, hier, Moment.
Es ist soweit.
Es ist soweit, Chat.
Jetzt können wir den Virgin Check machen.
Und ich bin nicht mehr safe.
Okay, Leute, warum, warum bin ich zu dumm?
Warum bin ich für Bildbearbeitung zu dumm?
Das muss doch, das muss doch, das muss doch, das muss doch, das muss doch, das muss doch.
Das muss doch irgendwie so funktionieren.
Man muss das doch irgendwie klippen können.
Ich will, ich will, dass keck weh, wird geklippt.
Aha, aha, Moment.
Was denn jetzt?
What the fuck?
Leute, ich bin so dumm.
Ich bin für Bildbearbeitung, bin ich einfach zu dumm, Alter.
Moment, ist das überhaupt ein, ist das, ist das überhaupt ein, ein GIF, was ich hier am Start hab?
Wo hab ich dieses komische Windows Logo denn her?
Windows, ah, das ist ein PNG.
Oh, mein PNG kann auch Transparenz haben.
Hat, hat das PNG Transparenz, was ich hier hab?
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ja, hat Transparenz.
Ich will das doch einfach nur klippen.
Ich will keck weh auf das Windows Logo klippen.
Leute, ihr wisst das doch bestimmt, wie das geht.
Guck mal, so, so, ich will einfach nur, dass das Windows Logo klippt.
Hä?
Ich bin zu, zu dumm.
Das muss doch so funktionieren.
Okay, Trick 17.
Wir machen das jetzt in Pixel, in Pixel machen wir das.
Oh, ich krieg's nicht hin.
Was, oben rechts den Magnet?
Was für ein, den Magnet?
Snapping.
Und dann?
Dann klippt's doch nicht.
Hm.
Also, ihr wisst ja, was ich vorhab, ne?
Also, ich will, ich will, dass das, das, das, das keck weh quasi durchschnitten wird von dem Windows Logo.
Ich, ich will das klippen ans Windows Logo, das, das, das keck, keck W.
Dass das hier quasi so eine Art Maske ist.
Das muss doch funktionieren.
Ach, scheiß auf Bildbearbeitung, ich bin da zu dumm für.
Ich bin zu dumm für Bildbearbeitung.
Ich kann das nicht.
Deswegen brauch ich jemanden, der Bildbearbeitung kann.
Felix, 10 Monate, dankeschön.
Big Brain.
Excellent Subscription.
MonkaS, Subscriber.
Äh, achso, wo war ich denn vorher stehen geblieben?
Ähm, ich hab schon wieder ganz vergessen.
Irgendwas mit CPU Temperatur, ne?
Choose my name, 6 Monate. Dankeschön.
Excellent.
Äh, ja, wie gesagt, ich würd einfach ne WPF-Anwendung machen.
Und warum kein UWP?
Weil man UWP entweder über Windows Store vertreiben muss.
Oder sich ein Codesigning-Zertifikat besorgen muss für 300 Euro im Jahr.
Was ziemlich...
...small brained ist.
Bringt es dir was, wenn ich mit Twitch Prime Testmodal abonniere?
Klar, mir bringt das immer was.
Wenn du das machen willst, wäre das natürlich wahnsinnig high IQ.
Moment, das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich zu blöd dafür bin.
Ich muss es jetzt nochmal probieren.
Ja, excellent.
Ah, kann es sein, dass ich Transparenz RGB einstellen muss?
Dass das so nicht stimmt?
Dass ich sagen muss RGB...
...web.
Dass ich hier irgendwie einstellen muss RGBA oder so?
Ich brauche ja keine Transparenz.
Guckt es euch an.
Genau das wollte ich machen.
Das wollte ich machen.
Das, was der Serious Marks jetzt gemacht hat.
Xsorix X Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Wow, ist das ein bisschen laut hier?
Genau das wollte ich machen.
Mach mal rechtlich auf das Windows Logo.
Okay, okay, Moment mal.
Also Desktop.
Wo ist das Windows Logo?
Date.
Windows Logo.
Und dann brauchen wir hier noch CagW.
CagW.
Okay.
Also was? Rechtsklick und dann?
Meinst du das da?
Restorize to Mask?
Und jetzt?
Und jetzt? Das unter die Maske?
Ne.
Das da.
Fast, ja!
Aber ich...
Ich will, dass das nicht...
Das ist fast das, was ich haben will.
Das ist...
Fast das, was ich haben will.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass... äh, warum ist denn das
jetzt so bleich? Warum ist das jetzt so
ausgeblichen?
Ich lass sowas lieber machen, ich bin da zu dumm für.
Whitewashing.
Excellent.
Weil das Logo nicht schwarz-weiß war.
Ach man, also ganz ehrlich, ohne Scheiß,
so eine Bildbearbeitung ist echt
nicht meins. Da bin ich...
Da bin ich komplett...
Komplett ein Noob drinne. Guckt's euch an.
Ich hätt's jetzt einfach so aufeinander
tracken dropped und ich seh halt, das funktioniert nicht.
Okay, genug gebastelt.
Aber sowas wollte ich
machen im Endeffekt.
Wobei es wahrscheinlich sogar noch cooler wär, wenn
für jedes Fenster
ein kleiner CagW drinne wär, oder?
Also dass man
quasi hier
nen bisschen abgeschnittenen, weil's von den
Seitenverhältnissen nicht passt,
bisschen abgeschnittenen CagW hat.
Hier ein bisschen abgeschnittenen CagW.
Oder noch viel besser, aus dem
kleinsten Video hier einen,
dann ein paar Frames weiter hier einen,
dass man vier unterschiedliche CagWs hat.
Im Windows-Logo.
Ich glaub, das sieht als Emote sogar ganz
gut aus in klein.
Ah ja, gut. Was auch immer.
Wir waren übrigens
davor, bis ich gesagt...
Bis ich festgestellt hab, dass ich hier...
mal zeigen, meine neueste Errungenschaft zeigen musste.
Ja, also Dankeschön, TrueMorphos,
für den Sub. Ich bin jetzt froh, dass ich endlich
PokiW spammen kann.
Wir waren davor beim CPU-Auslesen,
CPU-Temperatur auslesen. Also wie gesagt,
ich würd sagen, nimm einfach
WPF, mach ein WPF-Programm, da kannst du
nämlich hier transparente
Bilder anzeigen lassen als Overlay.
Und wie gesagt, so wie ich hier
transparente Bildchen anzeigen lassen kann, kannst du
dir auch transparente
CPU-Temperatur
anzeigen lassen. Allerdings muss man natürlich
dazu sagen, das gibt's ja schon.
Das gibt's ja schon fix und fertig.
VivoStill, das sieht irgendwie aber
ein bisschen nicht so richtig abgeschnitten aus
an der Seite.
Da ist hier, guckt, da ist hier
an der Seite noch zu viel dran hier.
Aber so ungefähr
hab ich mir das vorgestellt.
Wobei man halt
hier... Ich glaube, es wär besser, wenn man hier
nen Keg W hätte, hier und hier und hier.
Also Keg-Quad-Triple-U.
Ja, ähm...
Wenn du mir die
Files hochlädst, bau ich dir das nachher in ein Foto.
Ich hab die auf Google gesucht.
Das erste Windows-Logo, was ich auf Google...
Wow.
Paintschamp, Paintschamp, Paintschamp. Ich glaube,
das Board ist kaputt. Ja.
Zu viel Paintschamp.
Ja, das
empfinde ich aber, wenn ich Bildbearbeitung machen muss.
So wie es
jetzt ist, finde ich, sieht fast lustig aus.
Ja, ich finde, es hat irgendwie was.
Vielleicht könnte man es auch noch in Windows-Farben
machen oder so. Wie dem auch sei.
Ähm...
Also, für CPU-Temperatur
gibt es schon zig Programme, die das
im Overlay können.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass das Nvidia
in irgendeiner Art und Weise kann
im Overlay...
Ne, kann es nicht.
Kann nur FPS... Was? Viewer?
What the fuck?
Woher will Nvidia
meine Viewer wissen?
Siehst du, Nvidia hat keine Ahnung, wie viele Viewer ich hab.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch sehr gewundert,
wenn das Nvidia aus irgendwelchen Gründen wüsste.
Das hätte mich...
Da hätte ich eher bedenken, wenn die das auf einmal
gewusst hätten.
Ja, natürlich habe ich sie nicht mit Twitch verknüpft.
Warum sollte ich Nvidia mit Twitch verknüpfen?
Dann streame ich vielleicht noch irgendwann mal Sachen,
die ich nicht streamen will.
Das muss ja nicht sein, ja.
Ähm...
Also, das Windows 10 Logo mit 4x Keg W.
Ja, mal gucken, wie das
aussieht. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob das gut aussieht.
Wenn es nicht gut aussieht, musst du es gar nicht schicken.
Dann können wir es uns sparen, aber...
Ähm...
Ja.
Genau, wie gesagt, CPU-Temperatur auslesen dürfte
relativ einfach sein.
Und da gibt es auch schon zig fertige Sachen für.
Zum Beispiel hier, was ich früher immer verwendet habe,
war auch zum GPU übertakten,
war dieses MSI.
Was war das?
Der MSI Afterburner.
Kann den Namen falsch verstehen,
ich weiß, aber das ist ein Übertaktungstool.
Ähm...
Das war eigentlich
vom...
Das sieht halt übelst hängen geblieben.
Gaming, übertaktungsmäßig aus.
Aber das kann ganz gute Overlays.
Das kann Overlays für CPU-Temperatur
und GPU-Temperatur und so Zeug.
Wobei, ob es CPU-Temperatur kann, bin ich mir
jetzt gar nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hätte jetzt vermutet, dass es
CPU-Temperatur auch kann.
Aber bestimmt, bestimmt kann es auch CPU-Temperatur.
Also, das würde ich...
Das würde ich eher
empfehlen, als es selbst zu programmieren.
Oder geht es dir darum, einfach mal auszuprobieren,
sowas selbst zu programmieren? Ich weiß es leider nicht,
wer es gefragt hat, weil
ich den Chat-Refresh habe zwischendurch.
Also, wenn es natürlich einfach darum geht, dass du mal
ausprobieren willst, wie man sowas programmiert,
dann ist das eine richtig gute Idee.
Das könnten wir echt mal im
Stream ausprobieren.
Das ist ein super
kleines Mini-Programm,
was man mal im Stream zusammen machen könnte.
Aber
das müssen wir dann in
irgendwas anderem, als so einem 0815
Overlay, also wir machen da keine
WPF-Anwendungen, wir müssen da irgendwas abgedreht haben.
Dass wir sowas
Simples, weil im Prinzip ist das ja eine Schleife
mit ein paar Hardware-Abfragen
dabei, das sind wahrscheinlich 10 Zeilen oder so.
Das müssen wir noch in irgendwas...
Da muss doch irgendein Kniff dazu...
Wie man das...
Wie wir das machen können. Also,
ich kann jetzt natürlich einfach ein WPF-Fenster machen,
Transparenz anschalten und eine Schleife und ein paar
Requests CPU-Temperatur.
Aber...
Da kann man bestimmt noch ein bisschen... In Elektron...
Ist das dein Ernst?
Ne, in Elektron machen wir das bestimmt nicht.
Das machen wir vielleicht... Wir können
in Dings machen, in...
In Flutter können wir das
irgendwann mal machen. Ne, in C++ machen wir das
bestimmt nicht.
In C++ machen wir das bestimmt nicht.
Vor allem, es gibt ja in C++ auch keine
ordentliche Weg,
Windows-Programme zu machen, die
besser sind, oder schöner sind
als das in C Sharp.
Das ist gleich eklig, weil
wie gesagt, Microsoft hat keinen Bock
ordentliche UI-Frameworks zur Verfügung zu
stellen.
Ist C Sharp wirklich die Kurzform von
C++++?
Wie kommst du denn auf sowas?
Du meinst wegen der Raute, oder was?
Ich hab keine...
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Weil, keine Ahnung, woher das C Sharp kommt.
Ähm...
Ich...
Keine Ahnung, woher kommt das C Sharp-Name?
Ich glaube...
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Wahrscheinlich...
Ich finde die Erklärung mit den vier Plusen gar nicht so schlecht.
Außerdem heißt es ja auch
ähm...
C Lattenzaun, genau.
Guck mal,
Origin C Sharp Name Language.
Origin of the...
Stack Overflow, Stack Overflow weiß alles.
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen,
wie hat das unseren Azubi mal genannt?
War das C Lattenzaun?
Ich hab's letztens im Stream erzählt.
Ähm... Ja, ich glaube, er hat mal gesagt C Lattenzaun.
Alexia...
Excellent Subscription, Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Ähm...
Also, hier steht's doch.
C Sharp kommt von...
Was inspired by musical notation.
Aha.
Ähm...
Aber hier steht auch,
dass das Raute-Symbol
auch für vier Plusse
stehen kann.
Okay, ist auch...
Ist auch ne coole Erklärung, ja.
Hab ich noch nicht gehört bis jetzt.
Hab jetzt extra den Probemonat gemacht.
Eieieiei, Poggers, Dankeschön.
Denk dran, den Kram wieder abzubestellen,
wenn du ihn sonst nicht brauchst.
Ähm, weil ansonsten
ist hier
der Abogee-Bait am Start.
Gleich wieder abbestellen, klar.
Ja, hab schon gekündigt, das ist so.
So ist das, so macht man das.
Excellent.
Äh, T from
the future
abonniert für fünf Monate.
Heute ist aber der
Chat-IQ unglaublich hoch.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
So, okay, wir haben noch weitere Emote-Kandidaten
am Start.
Das find ich gut, das gefällt mir irgendwie.
Aber ich glaub, wenn das Emote
so klein ist, dann sieht man das
gar nicht richtig.
Was haben wir noch für Kandidaten?
Das erkennt man als Emote nicht.
Äh, das erkennt man als Emote nicht hier.
Das ist zu, glaub die Farben passen nicht, oder?
Das wird man als Emote nicht richtig erkennen.
Weil, weil
als Twitch-Emote ist das ganze Ding ja noch mal
noch mal kleiner.
Wobei,
weiß gar nicht, ob man das, erkennt man das,
wenn das noch kleiner ist?
Ne, das soll nicht unbedingt ein Emote werden.
Ich hatte bloß grad eine Idee.
Ähm, man könnte so ein Emote machen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das passt von der Größe her.
Ja, fürs Memeboard ist das auch nicht schlecht.
Ja, fürs Memeboard ist das gut,
da gefällts mir.
Ja, für das Dashboard ist das gut,
Was, das da? Ne, dann nehmen wir das da, oder?
Dann weiß auch wenigstens jeder, was gemeint ist.
Dann weiß auch jeder, was gemeint ist.
Denkt dran, Leute, ich kann nix löschen,
wenn ich's mal hinzugefügt hab.
Dann crasht das Ganze, wenn ich was versuch zu löschen.
Glaub ich zumindest.
KegWin
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht
schlecht.
Da können wir anstatt
Windows zu
KegWin, können wir gleich den Kram einblenden.
Dann kommt's in Chat.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das passt. Guck mal, das ist so klein.
Guck mal, also ungefähr so groß wär das dann
im Chat, würd ich mal sagen, ungefähr.
Das erkennt man nicht.
Das erkennt kein Mensch mehr im Chat, wenn das
diese Größe hat.
Da sieht man nix.
Dann ist die erste Variante, die wir hatten mit dem
durchgängigen KegWin
und dann hier dem, vielleicht besser.
Aber ist ja auch egal.
So, jetzt haben wir auch schon
die C-Sharp-Namen geklärt.
Geht ja hier richtig
zur Sache heute. Also, wie ihr dem
Stream-Titel ja schon entnehmen könnt,
ähm,
gibt's heute Komplett-Stream
ohne jeglichen
Sinn. Schon ein neues
Video in Planung, ja.
Aber ich hab immer neue Videos in Planung
und mach dann keinen.
Was?
Ah, MonkaS.
Da geh ich schnell drauf.
Ja, ich bin nicht mehr safe.
Leute, hört auf AdWoblos zu spammen.
Jetzt macht mein ganzes Board voll.
Ich weiß, was passiert,
wenn man das im Chat sagt.
Wenn man das im Chat sagt, spammen das alle.
Das ist normal.
Im Twitch-Chat darf man sowas nicht sagen.
Stimmt, wir haben kein .Files.
Äh, das könnten wir mal machen.
Das wäre echt nicht schlecht.
Ähm, Ausrufezeichen .Files
könnte man das Repo noch reinmachen.
Warum ist POG-U nicht aktiv?
Oh, tatsächlich ist es nicht.
Das müssen wir gleich mal machen.
frange-faces-z
äh, search POG-U
Zack, und schon
haben wir POG-U aktiv. So muss das sein.
Huge.
Ähm,
was?
POG-A
Mein Gott, es gibt so viele neue Emotes,
da blickt da keiner mehr durch.
POG-A, ne, das kenn ich, das ist dumm.
Das gefällt nicht, das kenn ich nicht.
Das ist dumm, deswegen habe ich mir das nicht gemerkt.
POG-A, das ist
bescheuert.
Es gibt auch viel Schwachsinn auf Twitch.
Um nicht zu sagen, fast alles.
POG-A ist trash.
So sieht es aus, Patrick.
Da sind wir mal einer Meinung.
Ähm,
ich muss mal kurz den Chat hier aufräumen.
Ich muss jetzt schneller löschen, als
der Chat was schreiben kann.
Schneller aufräumen, als der Chat posten kann.
Leute, ich kann
noch viel, es geht noch viel schneller.
Ich kann nämlich einfach Enter gedrückt halten.
Guckt überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich bin immer schneller.
Schneller als ihr.
Gar keine Chance.
Schau dir mal Cascadia Code Font an, was?
Ich habe so ziemlich alle
Code Fonts mir schon
angeguckt und Hack ist
eindeutig der, der mir am besten gefällt.
Oh.
Ist das einer, der
wie heißt das, diese
Sonderzeichen hat
für größer gleich, kleiner gleich?
Damit kann ich ja überhaupt nichts
anfangen. Doch, doch, das geht
auch. Ne, es geht nicht.
Guck mal das, Leute, es ist kaputt.
Der Button ist kaputt. Delete all geht nicht.
Debated.
Aber es kackt nicht ab.
Beste Seite für Twitch Copypasta,
die kenne ich, die kenne ich,
die kenne ich. Die gehört zu meinen
meist aufgerufenen
Seiten. Wichtig.
Ganz essentiell, dass man die besten
Twitch Copypastas kennt.
September
äh
Past
letzten Monat.
Oh Mann, das ist so Fail, Alter.
Ich habe noch nicht eine Minute
Pokimane geguckt bisher. Ich habe jetzt ein Abo
dafür, ja. Vollgas.
Roffel1436
Ich kenne das nur mit
Twitch kann aufeinander.
Gut, das hätten wir jetzt auch
geklärt. Ähm.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe echt
nichts vor, was wir heute
machen können. Ich habe gedacht, ich mache einfach
an.
Das heißt, ich bin jetzt darauf angewiesen, dass
Was ist das denn?
MacOS VirtualBox
Pushbutton Installer auf MacOS
Catalina
Mojave
Wie spricht man das eigentlich?
Pronunciation
Okay.
Mojave
high quality voice ok warum ok wikipedia 6 mojave mojave mojave klingt da voll hängen geblieben
was auch immer ja wir lassen uns das mal vorlesen mojave ernsthaft das heißt mojave mojave mojave
gut jetzt sind wir wieder schlauer geworden kann man die streammusik finden ja kann man aktuell ist
das ziemlich einfach es ist eine playlist top 300 nintendo songs of all time die geht zwölf
stunden dementsprechend reicht erst mal für heute also noch einmal was ist los drehen sie
durch er okay was ist das was was ist das ja push button installer arcana sagt dank die höre ich
jetzt beim lernen für die uni das kirby gomera ist ihm in der zehn stunden war ja das beste
leute wer das noch nicht macht davon kriegt man massiv großes gehirn
davon kriegt man massiv großes gehirn wenn man sich das anhört nur mal so jetzt als tipp weil ich
war man darf nicht vergessen ich habe immerhin lehrreich bei mir als tag drin im stream also
wenn ihr anfangen das zu hören ihr startet so ich starte ehrlich gesagt startet ihr so und quasi mit
jedem durchlauf bis nächstes mal rein passt und auch und auch wenn euch irgendwelche games auf
den sack gehen einfach hier an machen
was auch gut ist was auch was auch top ist ohne scheiß leute wenn ihr schlecht drauf seid ja oder
wenn ihr wenn irgendwas ist was euch voll auf den sack geht müsst ihr das hier an machen beste dann
danach danach ist man automatisch gut drauf beste hallo
success
youtube
das ist
nein
da bin ich
vivek
besser
das ist
Beste
Beste Song
Der vom zweiten Teil ist auch gut
We are out on Beta
We are re-releasing on time
To stay inside
Maybe you'll find someone else to talk to
Maybe Black Mesa
Haha
Sing FPS
And when you're dead I will be still alive
Still alive
Und Chat, ich garantiere euch, alle die schlecht drauf waren, sind jetzt besser drauf
Vielleicht auch nicht, weil ich mitgesungen hab, da kann ich verstehen, dass das
eher verstörend wirkt, als dass man besser drauf ist
Da ist es eher sowas dann
Aber beste, beste, ohne Scheiß, Leute
Wenn ihr schlecht drauf seid, dann lasst ein Abo da
Ihr müsst euch das Portal 1, den Portal 1 Outro songen
Der Portal 2 Song ist auch nicht schlecht
Aber ich finde, Portal 1 Song ist noch besser
Weiß nicht, mal gucken, was ihr besser findet
Also ich finde den Portal 1 Song besser
Kill me twice
Take it
Generell die Portal Musik ist übelst nice
Now I just want you gone
Oh, only want you gone, fast
Not quite as heavy
One day they woke me up
So I could live forever
It's such a shame until you
You got your choice and I dance
One day they woke me up
So I could live forever
It's such a shame until you
To you
You got your choice and I dance
Oh, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Das ist eine gute Variante davon.
Hä?
Und jetzt?
Warum kann man das nicht runterladen?
Keck.
Pass auf, ich mach das mal mit dem VLC.
Auf dem VLC geht das bestimmt.
Ja, geil, keine Hektik.
Bilder im VLC öffnen, wenn es nicht geht.
Ah.
Okay.
Das geht, ja.
Wie hast du die Bilduhr da jetzt rausgekriegt?
Inspect.
Ah, excellent.
Das ist ja big brainig, dass man das braucht.
Ups.
Oder auch nicht hier.
Kein Kabel hier.
Ah.
Download.
Was ich aber trotzdem merke,
ich will die Kamera das hier nicht irgendwie richtig runterladen.
Ich mein, hä?
Das geht nicht, oder was?
Ist das jetzt Windows-Logik,
oder ist das jetzt Browser-Fail?
Oder hab ich mir jetzt irgendwie hier den krassen Hack gemacht?
Ich hab den krassen Hack gemacht.
Ich hab den krassen Hack eingefangen,
der hat euch durch das PNG aufgemacht.
Man weiß es ja nie, ja.
Ah, Windows, oder?
Okay.
Dann gucken wir mal,
dann machen wir den gerade mal.
Wir gucken, ob das Löschen funktioniert, Leute.
Es kann sein, dass es jetzt crasht, ja.
Oh, es hat funktioniert.
Poggers.
Äh.
Das finde ich gut als Cake.
Perfekt für neue Text-to-Speech.
Äh.
Die Seite mache ich jetzt nicht auf.
15.8.
Klingt irgendwie vom Namen her.
Findet ihr nicht auch?
15.8.
Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen monkatos.
Geradezu fast schon.
Wo ist er?
Ich finde ihn nicht.
Na, gerade schon fast so?
Diese komische Playlist,
die kann sich echt nicht entscheiden,
ob laut oder leise.
Na gut.
Aber Leute, ne.
Wenn man den Portal 1 Song gehört hat,
geht es einem instant besser.
Wir waren ja eigentlich dabei,
da ich gucken wollte, was das hier ist.
Und irgendwie sind wir dann gesitetrackt worden,
weil ich wissen wollte,
wie man Mojave ausspricht.
Woblos, das Fachgespräch heute war echt Eats.
Du hattest recht.
Nice.
Was hast du für ein Abschlussprojekt gemacht,
da Kupfermann?
Excellent.
Wenn das Eats war.
Was hast du als Abschlussprojekt gemacht?
Okay, also meinst du,
die Seite kann man aufmachen?
Ja, die Seite kann man aufmachen.
Ich hab's.
Ich hab's schon mal so probiert.
Was?
Please take a few months to read about the page.
Hä?
Was?
Aber Source kannst du.
Ah, Portal.
Okay.
Ja, wo kann ich jetzt Text eingeben?
Awaiting input.
Äh.
Adblock aus?
Nee, oder?
Ach, cute.
29.
About-Seite.
About.
App.
Ah, yes.
Ähm.
Keck, W, Ubuntu.
Keck, Ubuntu.
Ey, das ist cool.
Das kann das sonst noch.
Oh ja, unbedingt.
Wir brauchen, wir brauchen Fluttershy.
Fluttershy brauchen wir unbedingt.
Ganz, ganz wichtig.
Keck, Ubuntu.
Oh, nein.
Oh, das ist ja schlimm.
Das ist, oh.
Ich, das, das klingt ja fast schon Porn-mäßig, ja.
Keck, Ubuntu.
Oh, was, was können wir noch mal anderes ausprobieren?
Was haben wir hier sonst?
Piss dich, Alde.
Genau.
Guck mal.
Piss dich, Alde.
Scheiße.
Das klappt nicht.
Piss dich, Piss dich, Alde.
Piss dich, Alde.
Alter, die Seite ist gut.
Haben die eine API?
Piss dich, Alde.
Haben die eine API, die man verwenden kann?
Ich meine, man kann natürlich die Seite nachmachen, ja, aber, ähm, also, die, da haben wir so einen Browser, äh, äh, simulieren, aber schöner wäre es, wenn die, haben die eine, äh, ähm, muss man sich mal, muss man sich mal überlegen, also, cool.
Äh, nice, ja, was es, was es nicht alles gibt, äh, mach mal Persona 4, nee, das ist mir zu.
Heute.
Zu, zu sehr.
Hier ist die Moab, ja.
Das müssen wir testen.
Tatsächlich.
Hier ist die Moab.
Das, da kommt aber nichts Gescheites raus, wenn die das auf Englisch aussprechen.
Guck mal, das, das überfordert ihn schon.
Da, da kommt, da kommt er nicht klar mit.
Doch, jetzt.
Hier ist die Moab.
Oh.
Das hört sich echt an wie irgendein Porn.
Das hört sich echt an, das kann man, das ist ja...
Here is die Mobe.
Here is die Mobe, alles klar.
Gut, natürlich klappt das Ganze nicht, weil die betonen ja alles Englisch.
Gut, um jetzt mal zur eigentlichen Sache zurück.
Erstmal gucken, ich habe schon drei Spiele an Fragen übersehen.
Persona 4, ne, heute nicht.
Genau, Fachgespräch, stimmt.
Was hast du denn für ein Abschlussprojekt?
Hast du schon geschrieben?
Ah, hier.
Hipster Web-Tool zur Geräteverwaltung.
Okay.
Was haben sie so gefragt?
Was wollten die so wissen?
Kobol, ja, ich weiß.
Kobol mache ich auch noch irgendwann.
Da muss ich aber nämlich schon sehr...
Da muss ich irgendwas ordentliches an dem Tag schon...
...gemacht haben, dass ich mich selbst ein bisschen quälen kann.
Ach, okay.
Also das übliche Zeug.
Projektverwaltung, wie sind sie das Projekt angegangen?
Bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Wie hast du das Mapping gemacht?
Okay.
Haben sie dir auch total random sinnlose Fragen gestellt?
So nach dem Motto, ähm...
Auf welcher OSI-Modell-Schicht wird ihre Web-Anwendung betrieben oder sowas?
Hast du schon was von der Noise-Canceling-AI von Nvidia gehört?
Ja.
Haben wir uns aber noch nicht angeguckt.
Äh, Swiss-Shock-Rack-X?
Überseht.
Da hast du aber die Hardcore-Prüfer, ey.
Also meine Prüfer hätten da auch null durchge...
...durch...
...geblickt.
Aha.
Nein, das ist doch schon mal was.
Aber wenn du sagst, es war easy, gehe ich...
Ich glaube, das war...
...wahrscheinlich echt easy.
Ich habe auch...
Was?
Moment, hier.
Was schreibt da das?
Liebling Chris.
Ich habe auch noch mega Angst vor meiner mündlichen Prüfung.
Ich mache Physio im Projekt.
War ein Debian.
War ein Repository-Spiegel.
Äh, der im Unternehmen per SSH erreichbar ist...
...und die Config der Clients wird per Ensemble ausgerollt.
Warum hast du...
Warum hast du Angst vor einer mündlichen Prüfung?
Hast du irgendwie Bedenken, dass die dich was fragen, wo du was noch nicht weißt?
Also die müssen dich ja was Projektbezogenes fragen.
Ich weiß, dass die das manchmal nicht machen, aber...
...ähm...
...es muss Bezug zu deinem Projekt haben.
Und...
...fast alle, die ich kenne, sagen, es war easy as fuck.
Äh, also PC-lustig.
Ich kenne jemanden, der ist durchgefallen.
Ich kenne jemanden, der ist durchgefallen bei der IHK-Prüfung, ja.
Aber, da muss man dazu sagen...
...der Typ, der hatte, äh...
...andere Stärken als IT.
Es war nämlich...
...ich hatte...
...der hatte ich schon erzählt in der Berufsschule.
Der war bei mir in der Berufsschulklasse.
Der war vorher, ähm...
...Steinmetz.
Muss gerade überlegen, wie das heißt.
Der war vorher Steinmetz.
Und dem ist dort auf der Arbeit was auf den Fuß gefallen.
Und daraufhin hat ihm sein ehemaliger Chef quasi...
...einen Fachinformatikersystemintegration-Ausbildungsplatz, ähm...
...besorgt.
So nach dem Motto, ja, hier.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er ihm was Gutes tun wollte, ja.
Das Problem war nur, der hatte halt wirklich...
...gar keine Ahnung.
Gar keine Ahnung, der, der...
...der Kerl.
Der hat es auch geschafft, in der Datenbankarbeit...
...zwei von hundert Punkten zu kriegen, weil er zweimal...
...Create Table geschrieben hat.
Also der Kerl hatte wirklich gar keine Ahnung.
Und der ist am Ende auch durchgefallen durch die IHK-Prüfung.
Aber das ist der einzige, den ich kenne, der durchgefallen ist.
Aber wie gesagt, sleepingchrist, du musst dir da...
...keine Gedanken machen.
Die Abschlussprüfung ist wirklich...
...total einfach.
Und, ähm...
...und das Projekt klingt doch auch gut, hier.
Das Projekt klingt doch auch gut.
Wenn du, wenn du das sinnvoll verkauft hast...
...ähm...
...warum du das Projekt brauchst, wie du das Ganze angegangen hast...
...wenn du da vielleicht sogar...
...wo, wo sie, wo sie, wo sie dann richtig...
...äh, Tränen in den Augen haben werden, ist, wenn du vielleicht sogar...
...ein Gant-Diagramm gemacht hast oder sowas.
Kennt diesen Schrott?
Ja.
Das kennt überhaupt irgendjemand.
Da, da haben sie Tränen in den Augen vor Freude bei der IHK...
...wenn du, wenn du ein Gant-Diagramm machst.
So, mein Gott, fuck, Alter, ein Gant-Diagramm.
Da geht ne, da geht ne richtig eine ab, ähm...
...äh, haben wir noch nicht gemacht, David...
...äh, Schar.
Ich hab das Projekt gerade zum ersten Mal gefunden, ja...
...also so ein komisches Ablauf-Gant-Diagramm.
Da gehen sie ab drauf, das finden sie wahnsinnig schön.
Hatte ich bei mir auch in der Abschlussarbeit eins drinne.
Und...
...ich hab das gemacht...
...mit...
...so...
...aber auch nur...
...weil das vorinstalliert war und mein Chef damals gemeint hat...
...ähm, das, das wäre irgendwie die beste Software dafür.
Da hatte er im Nachhinein aber keine Ahnung.
Und ich sag euch, Leute...
...ich hab selten so eine Scheiß-Software gesehen wie MS-Project.
Ich hab damit nie wieder was gemacht danach, ja.
Aber allein schon dieses Gant-Diagramm da drin zu erstellen...
...war so ein abgrundtiefer Scheiß.
Jetzt, jetzt ohne Übertreibung, ja.
Ohne, ohne, ohne Spaß, Leute.
Ne.
Ne, fass ich nie wieder an.
Nie wieder.
Nie, nie wieder fass ich das an.
Das hätte ich jetzt auch besser in Excel machen sollen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin ja jemand, der gar kein Office verwendet.
Ich verwende für nichts Office.
Und das Einzige, was eine Daseinsberechtigung hat von Office, ist nach wie vor Excel.
Den Rest braucht man nicht.
Der Rest ist komplett...
...ploated...
...überflüssiger Schwachsinn.
So.
Ähm...
Ja, ja, muss man ja, muss man ja machen.
Das machen wir jetzt gleich.
Ah, da musste...
...da musste...
...Augen zu und durch.
Ich weiß, das hört sich jetzt blöd an, weil das werden wahrscheinlich alle sagen.
Aber wenn du...
...damit fertig bist, es interessiert sich echt kein Mensch mehr dafür.
Du kannst, du kannst den größten Mist in der Prüfung zusammen, zusammen reden, zusammen stammeln am Endeffekt.
Solange du den Kram bestehst, ist es gar kein Problem.
Und es fällt eigentlich keiner durch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Durchfallquoten sind.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob da überhaupt Leute durchfallen können aktuell.
Ähm...
Es wird sich kein Mensch mehr für diese Prüfung jemals interessieren.
Also du kannst den...
Du kannst...
Du kannst die schlechteste Präsentation auf der Welt machen.
Ähm...
Solange du es bestehst, was du machen wirst, allein schon mit so einem Projekt.
Es interessiert danach wirklich absolut keine Sau mehr.
Ach ja, mit meinen Berichtsheften.
Weiß ich nicht, ob ich das schon erzählt habe.
Ähm...
Meine...
Ich hab ja...
Ich hab ja keine Ausbildungsberichte geschrieben.
Also man muss ja...
Äh...
Muss ja in der IHK muss man ja...
Ähm...
Äh...
Ausbildungs...
Ne, wie heißen die Dinger?
Äh...
Berichte.
Man muss so Ausbildungsberichte...
Äh...
Berichte schreiben.
Gibt's da...
Gibt's da sowas?
Ja!
Da!
So sieht das aus.
So...
So sieht das aus, was man da schreiben muss.
So.
Ähm...
Da schreibt man dann so Zeug rein, wie...
Wie...
Wie was er hier...
Was er hier zum Dreien geschrieben hat.
Besprechung gegen Self-Service Terminal...
Bla bla bla bla bla.
So.
Ähm...
Bei mir war das so.
Ich hab...
Die ersten vier Wochen...
Äh...
Eventuell könntest du mal deine Abschlusspräsentation zeigen.
Ähm...
Ja.
Vielleicht.
Da muss ich mal gucken, ob da nix...
Äh...
Nix unternehmensspezifisches drinne ist.
Ja, das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Das ist ne gute Idee.
Ähm...
Abschluss...
Sachen löschen mit...
Na...
Muss ich mir noch den schreiben.
Das kann ich echt mal machen.
Hab ich jetzt ne Video-Idee?
Ne, ne.
Ist keine Video-Idee.
Wobei, das ist eigentlich auch ne gute...
Auch ne gute Video-Idee.
Ist eigentlich auch ne gute Video-Idee.
Ah, cool.
Warum steht da Abschlussprüfung als Video-Idee?
Ach, dass ich die Story erzählen kann.
Zumindest, was ich von den Ausbildungs...
Von den Ausbildungsnachweisen, ähm...
Erzählen wollte, ist...
Ich hab die ersten vier Wochen Ausbildungsnachweise geschrieben.
Und, ähm...
Danach...
Wie lang geht das? Drei Jahre oder so?
Nichts.
Gar nix.
Und das Problem war halt, dass, ähm...
Irgendwann so...
Bei...
Kurz vor der Prüfung...
Irgendwann wurd's dann halt so langsam eng.
Also, kurz vor der Prüfung wurd's dann langsam eng.
Ne, also sprich, ich hatte dann...
Ich hatte dann ungefähr drei Jahre...
Ich musste drei Jahre Ausbildungsberichte nachholen.
So, und was ich dann gemacht hab, ist...
Ähm...
Nachdem sich...
Nachdem ich vermutet habe, dass ich für diese...
Ähm...
Diese Ausbildungsberichte...
Dass sie nur wöchentlich waren, ne, ja?
Oder?
Ich glaube, die waren nur wöchentlich.
So, nachdem ich ja eh schon die Vermutung hatte,
dass ich für diese Ausbildungsberichte...
Ausbildungsberichte kein Mensch interessieren würde,
bin ich hergegangen und hab einfach mir ein paar Sachen überlegt.
So, weiß was ich, 20, 30, 40 oder so.
Verschiedene Sachen, die man immer mal wieder macht.
So, Rechenzentrumsrundgang und solche Sachen, ja?
Ähm...
Rechenzentrumsrundgang, tägliches Teammeeting, bla bla bla bla bla bla.
So was, ja?
So, ähm...
Und...
Bin ich hergegangen...
Und hab einfach diese 40 Punkte, mehr oder weniger random, auf 3 Jahre Berichte verteilt.
So.
Und das Problem an der ganzen Geschichte war dann aber noch,
mein Chef musste den ganzen Kram unterschreiben.
Weil ohne Unterschrift geht das natürlich nicht.
So.
Und dann hab ich die ganzen Ausbildungsberichte genommen und hab mein Chef gesagt,
Alter, willst du mich verarschen?
Soll ich das jetzt alles unterschreiben?
Er hat gesagt, ja, passt schon.
Er hat gesagt, nee, nee, lass das mal hier den anderen machen.
Und dann hat das dann der Stellvertreter vom Chef gemacht.
Und der Stellvertreter vom Chef damals hat gesagt, weißt du was?
Nimm einfach die eingescannte Unterschrift von mir und mach's drunter.
Also hab ich die Unterschrift, die eingescannte Unterschrift genommen
und unter jedes, unter jeden Ausbildungsbericht druntergepackt und ausgedruckt.
Fertig.
Hat gut funktioniert.
Na gut, nee, ehrlich gesagt, das hat nicht gut funktioniert.
Das kann ich keinem empfehlen, so zu machen.
Hast du die, das in Word geschrieben?
Nein.
gesagt, wenn
meine Präsentation auf der Kippe gestanden
hätte, hätten sie mich wieder heimgeschickt mit
den Berichten. Aber nachdem ich 95%
bei meiner Präsentation gekriegt
habe, wohlgemerkt, 95%,
nicht 100%, ja,
95% haben sie gesagt, eh, wurscht, ich soll
jetzt, ich hab bestanden und tschüss.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, ich hab
schon so oft gesagt, ja, dass ich
extrem faul bin, was sowas angeht
und dass ich immer nur
das, das, das kleinstmögliche
mache, was nötig ist,
aber dementsprechend halten meine Lösungen
auch immer.
Das, was ich mache, funktioniert dann am Ende, weil
ich keinen Bock hab, es zweimal zu machen.
So, ähm, also
was gibt's da, was haben wir noch so für Quests?
Das genau hab ich gestern in PHP programmiert.
Exzellent. Ja.
Ja, wenn da aber nur 30 Punkte stehen
und immer mal random zwischendrin wieder
Rechenzentrums rundgang, es hat schon
sehr verdächtig gewickt. Aber im Endeffekt
ist, wie du sagst, es interessiert eigentlich keinen
Mensch. Wahrscheinlich können die dich aufgrund der
Ausbildungsnachweise gar nicht durchfallen lassen.
Ist wahrscheinlich kompletter Blödsinn gewesen, den sie einfach nur
gesagt haben.
Wie wäre es mit einem Tool, um es...
Das ist eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Ey, das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Das gefällt mir.
Tool zum
Ausbildungsberichte generieren.
Das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Das gefällt mir.
Das ist exzellent.
Ähm...
Ilo W. schreibt gerade seine Projektdoku.
Was hast du für ein Projekt?
Wie gesagt, ich hab ein VPN gebaut.
Bei Lokizu steht, äh,
sagt, bei mir steht gefühlt
zu 90% Trainer Access Point getauscht,
Tastatur getauscht, Drucker überprüft.
Okay, das ist aber wirklich, äh,
Low-End-Support-Crap.
Da hätt ich keinen Bock drauf.
Was nimmst du als Textverarbeitung
beziehungsweise Latex? Äh, äh,
gar nicht, gar nicht.
Ich mach das so weit es geht in Markdown alles.
Also eigentlich, eigentlich, zum größten,
eigentlich fast alles Plaintext.
Markdown ist ja Plaintext.
Das Vorteil an Markdown ist,
es sieht gut lesbar in Plaintext aus
und wenn man es ein bisschen hübscher haben will,
kann man sich das HTML generieren.
Warum bei der mündlichen Prüfung noch 95%
und keine 100%?
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie keine 100% vergeben wollten.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Und da kann man irgendeinen x-beliebigen Markdown-Editor nehmen.
Ich nehm meistens Whistle Studio Code,
weil es standardmäßig markdownmäßig ganz gut ist.
Gut funktioniert drinne.
Ähm...
Aber ansonsten ist es eigentlich wurscht, was man da nimmt.
Könntest du das machen?
Warte mal, das ist ja echt gut die Idee.
Kann man ein paar Körner abfragen?
Ah, excellent. Das ist nice.
IOW schreibt,
er hat als Abschlussprojekt aussuchen.
Das heißt bestimmt nicht aussuchen, oder?
Das hast du bestimmt ein bisschen schöner geschrieben.
Evaluierung und implementieren
wäre da so ein Stonkswort für.
Also aussuchen und implementieren
eines Monitoring-Systems
mit automatischer E-Mail-Benachrichtigung.
Okay, ja.
Das ist super.
Aber wie ist ihr Abschlussprojekt?
Das ist das, was ich vielen Azubis auch schon gesagt hab bei uns.
Wir haben ja leider gerade weniger,
aber die, die da waren,
denen hab ich das fast alle gesagt,
dass beim Abschlussprojekt
nicht so sehr drauf ankommt,
dass das technisch wahnsinnig komplex ist,
sondern, dass du es gut verkaufst,
beziehungsweise, dass du das reinbringst,
was die IHK sehen will.
Also die IHK will nicht sehen,
dass man sagt, ich baue einen Zabbix auf.
Die IHK will sehen,
dass was hier zum Beispiel
der IHK,
der ILO-W, schreibt.
Implementierung,
Evaluierung, Implementieren eines Monitoring-Systems
mit automatischer E-Mail-Benachrichtigung.
Die Auswahl würde vielleicht sogar auch schon reichen,
wenn man einen Testaufbau macht.
Implementierung eines Monitoring-Systems
ist eigentlich viel zu lang
für die Abschlussprojektarbeit.
Also wenn du schreiben würdest,
du evaluierst Monitoring-Systeme
und machst dann einen Testaufbau,
würde voll und ganz reichen.
Man muss dann einfach alle die ganzen Geschichten
dabei machen, die die IHK gerne sieht.
Ja, irgendeinen Ablauf,
Diagramm, irgendeine Ressourcenplanung,
schöne Matrix, wie du die Produkte evaluiert hast
und was gewinnt.
Natürlich kann das komplett gefaked sein.
Bei mir war es auch gefaked.
Bei mir hat am Ende OpenVPN gewonnen,
aber ich wusste schon,
dass ich mit OpenVPN bauen will.
Da muss man sich halt ein paar Sachen zusammen reiben,
im Zweifelsfall.
Felix Spitzer sagt,
glaube auch, dass systematisch niedriger bewertet wird.
Keiner kauft dir die Qualität einer Ausbildung ab,
wenn 90 Prozent der Leute maximale Punktzahl haben.
Das ist richtig.
Übrigens, die Qualität der Ausbildung bei der IHK,
ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendjemand noch was drauf gibt.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall ziemlich,
wenn man irgendwas auf diese Ausbildung gibt.
Eigentlich könnte man sich diese Ausbildung komplett sparen,
wenn wir in Deutschland nicht so extrem Wert darauf legen würden,
dass man irgendwelchen Zettel in der Hand hat.
Zabbix hat bei dir gewonnen.
Ja, das ist eine super Sache.
Aber du musst natürlich zeigen, warum Zabbix gewinnt.
Das ist ja wichtig.
Also du musst da reinschreiben.
Du musst dir da so eine Bewertungsmatrix ausdenken.
So eine Bewertungsmatrix ausdenken.
Sowas hier, sowas hier.
Und da denkst du dir halt eigene Kriterien aus,
was dein Monitoring System erfüllen muss.
Also was weiß ich zum Beispiel,
wie viele Benachrichtigungsmethoden unterstützt das von SMS bis Webhooks,
bis E-Mails, bis sonst was.
Ja, dann in welchem Intervall.
Kann.
Du kannst die Punkte ja auch so zusammen faken,
dass im Endeffekt Zabbix gewinnt.
Ja.
Ja, wenn ich eine Bachelorarbeit schreiben würde,
die würde ich nicht in Markdown machen.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Ich kann mir immer nicht machen, ob das LaTeX oder LaTech heißt.
Dafür hat das natürlich seinen Anwendungszweck.
Aber für die tägliche Arbeit ist Markdown das Beste, was man verwenden kann.
Plaintext ist das Beste, was man verwenden kann.
Markdown auch nur aus dem Grund bei mir,
weil man es halbwegs schön formatieren kann auf Knopfdruck.
Also in Word würde ich es auf gar keinen Fall machen.
Word ist für den Arsch.
Ich hatte keine Formeln in meiner Abschlussarbeit.
Formel war zu Big Brains für die IHK.
Die IHK liebt Wirtschaftszeug.
Ja, da hat das Liebling Chris komplett recht.
Zumindest, man muss so ein bisschen Projektmanagement gedönst drum herum labern.
So ein bisschen stonks gelabern muss in die Abschlussarbeit rein.
Wie gesagt, da haben sie feuchte Augen bei der IHK und freuen sich.
Wäre mal interessant, wie du meine Dokumentation bewerten würdest.
Dibaro, die würde ich mir sehr gerne angucken,
aber die kann man wahrscheinlich nicht auf dem Stream zeigen wegen Daten.
Sicherheitssicherheit, da gehe ich mal von aus.
Aber wenn du willst, kann ich mir das nochmal angucken.
Nutzwertanalyse, ah, excellent.
Ich sehe schon, heute ist Big Brain Chat wieder am Start.
Wirst du nochmal ein Studium anfangen?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich habe mir das vor ein paar Jahren mal überlegt,
aber die Sache ist die, ich habe da keinen wirklichen Antrieb zu.
Weil bei mir ist es so, ich mache sowas nicht unbedingt,
weil ich so krass ehrgeizig bin und sage,
ich will jetzt auch noch irgendwie einen Titel haben oder das haben und jenes haben.
Ich bin vollkommen zufrieden mit dem, was ich mache da auf der Arbeit.
Ich bin auch mit dem Gehalt mittlerweile ganz, ganz gut zufrieden.
Und was, wo ich quasi in der Berufswelt jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr zufrieden bin,
mache ich quasi mit meinem zweiten Job.
Also sei es jetzt hier auf, wenn ich mal wieder mal irgendeinen Aktivitätsanfall auf YouTube habe
oder wenn ich jede Menge Streams mache oder sonst was.
Also das ist für mich das, was ich mache.
Das ist für mich der beste Ausgleich.
Ich werde nichts studieren.
Garantiert nicht.
ILOW, also Dokumentationstechnik mit Word, ist komplett bescheuert.
Also ich weiß, du kannst da nichts dran ändern.
Das hat wahrscheinlich irgendjemand bei euch entschieden im Management.
Aber Word zur Dokumentation ist bescheuert.
Dokumentation muss mal sein, was von allen lesbar ist.
Also irgendein Wiki oder so.
Meinetwegen wird es sein, muss sogar Confluence.
Da stehen ja die Stonks BWL-Management-Leute drauf.
Ja, ist eben auch. Können wir machen.
Okay, also was ist das jetzt?
Ich habe den Chat jetzt durchgelesen, alles klar.
Was ist das hier jetzt nochmal genau?
Push-Button-Installer auf macOS Catalina in VirtualBox for Windows, Linux und Mac.
Also das ist ein Skript, wie man macOS in VirtualBox installiert.
Okay.
VirtualBox unmodified.
Fuck.
Unmodified macOS Installation.
Files download direct from Apple Servers.
Test is sequent.
Das haben wir nicht installiert.
Work on macOS Windows Subsystem for Linux.
In CentOS 7.
Aha.
Das könnten wir tatsächlich gerade mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe aber gar keine VirtualBox drauf.
Wir gucken uns das Skript erstmal an.
Was macht denn der Dude da?
Okay, das ist mir zu lang.
Das gucke ich mir nicht an.
Das ist ja...
What the fuck?
Ha.
Scheiße, Alter.
1500 Zeilen Shell-Skript.
Da lag der Browser.
Seht ihr das?
Der Browser lag da.
Das ist Massive Big Brain Shell-Skript.
Ähm.
Yemex.
Äh, nee.
Yemtex.
Ist Yemtex der Nachfolger von Semtex?
Ist das hier ein Call of Duty Name?
Nee, oder?
Ähm.
Gibt es in der IT einen Job, der etwas mehr Abwechslung hat?
Ja.
Das ist alles.
Also, es gibt kaum ein Themengebiet, was so unterschiedliche Jobs hat wie IT.
IT ist ja ein riesen, ein riesen Feld.
Ja, da kannst du...
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist, das ist quasi von Druckerpatronen tauschen bis Anwendungsentwicklung
zu Cloud-Big-Data-Geschichten, AI und noch alles, ist da alles dabei.
Ja.
Ähm.
Er fragt noch weiter.
Hätte gerne eine Bezeichnung für einen Job.
Zurzeit arbeite ich 40 Stunden nur als Softwareentwickler.
Aber ich würde...
Achso.
Ah, da habe ich es falsch verstanden.
Da habe ich das Intro falsch verstanden.
Aber ich würde gerne mehr Abwechslung haben im Sinne von mehr mit Kunden...
Oh.
Okay, da bin ich der Falsche.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich mit Kunden nichts zu tun habe.
Ähm.
Hardware, IT, Server, Security zu tun haben.
Wenn es geht, so einen Allrounder.
Äh.
Ja.
Also, wenn man das so machen kann, was gerade auch schwer angesagt ist, ist einmal Full-Stack-Developer.
Das würde ja bei dir passen als Softwareentwickler.
Das ist natürlich jetzt von der Firma abhängig.
Also, das ist zurzeit so ein Buzzword-Ding.
Also, quasi von Frontend bis Backend bis Applikationsserver bis alles.
Oder, äh, DevOps-Engineer ist zurzeit auch so ein Ding.
Was für dich beides als Programmierer, ähm...
Also, wo das, wenn du gerade Softwareentwickler bist, sicherlich eine super Grundlage für ist.
Consultant auch Kundenkontakt.
Das wird ja immer schlimmer, Chat.
Full-Cack-Developer.
Ja, da muss man ein bisschen schauen, ähm, was die jeweilige Firma haben will, ja.
Was schreibt denn, was schreibt denn zum Beispiel Skill-Crush?
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Die schreiben...
Was war mal?
Frontend, Backend, Full-Stack.
Full-Stack ist super, super Beschreibung.
What the fuck?
Die meisten Backends...
Okay, PHP vielleicht, aber die meisten Backends werden weder in Ruby, PHP oder Python sein.
Vor allem Java-Zeug, wenn es Enterprise ist.
Ja, aber das sind zwei Sachen, wo ich, wo ich denke, dass es gerade für dich als Softwareentwickler mit, ähm, quasi...
Big-Brain-Hintergrund super Geschichte ist.
Gerade sowas hier.
Das ist ja das im Prinzip mehr oder weniger, was ich auch mache.
Ja.
Also, wenn es dich interessiert, was ich mache.
Ich habe dazu mal ein Video gemacht.
Das da.
Da habe ich ein bisschen zu ausgelassen, was ich quasi als DevOps-Engineer mache.
Aber das ist sehr unternehmensabhängig und auch sehr wenig genau suchen und welche Rolle man hat.
Aber das sind so die zwei Sachen, die sind gerade voll angesagt, ja.
Und da hast du sicherlich mehr Abwechslung, als den ganzen Tag, äh, Java zu editieren.
Ja, ich hoffe, das hat, äh...
Bringt dir als Antwort jetzt was.
Weiß nicht, ob du schon was geschrieben hast.
So irgendwas gibt.
Ja, der, der Jetschi baitet heute wieder, ha.
SAP-Consulting, Alter.
Pain-Champ.
Moment.
Wir haben einen Befehl?
Wir haben einen Befehl für das, was ich auf der Arbeit mache?
Ernsthaft?
Sebarro.
Hier.
Sehr gut, dass wir so einen Befehl haben.
Oder Patrick.
Ich weiß nicht, wer es...
Oder Sirius, ich weiß nicht, wer es eingerichtet hat.
Oder das Evoli.
Wo ist das Evoli eigentlich?
Lange nicht mehr gesehen, ja.
Ähm...
Das kann ich, das kann ich voll verstehen.
Ja, im Text.
Er schreibt hier gerade, arbeite halt zur Zeit 40 Stunden als Softwareentwickler und hatte immer Spaß am Programmieren.
Ähm...
Aber jeden Tag acht Stunden lang zu programmieren, irgendwann habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich meinen Leidenschaftspfiff liere.
Kann ich voll verstehen, ja.
Kann ich, kann ich sehr gut, sehr, sehr, sehr gut nachvollziehen.
Würde, würde mir wahrscheinlich ähnlich gehen.
Ähm...
Vor allem halt, wenn es acht, acht Stunden was ist, wo man jetzt vielleicht auch nicht so unbedingt scharf drauf ist, ja.
Also, ich denke, gerade sowas hier ist, was abwechslungsmäßig angeht, ist halt, das ist so ein bisschen Wildcard, ja.
Kann mehr oder weniger alles sein.
Aber gerade du als Softwareentwickler ist das natürlich eine super Grundlage dafür.
Oftmals ist das ja auch ein bisschen so die, die Schnittstelle zwischen Entwicklung, Administration und, und teilweise...
Ähm...
Support, Operating und sonst was.
Äh...
Testtools, Automatisierungsgeschichten.
Also hier hast du auf jeden Fall, je nach, je nach Firma und je nach Position, was man da genau macht, hast du jede Menge Abwechslung.
Ähm...
Natürlich...
Programmierst du dann halt auch nicht für den ganzen Tag, ist ja logisch, ne.
Aber ist ja auch das, was du nicht mehr machen willst.
Also...
Gerade wenn man, wenn man Programmierer ist, ist das, denke ich, auch eine super Grundlage dafür.
Full, Fullstack Developer und DevOps Engineer.
Genau.
Da kannst du auch hier Golem Jobs oder irgendwo gucken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man...
Ja, oder Stepstone oder so.
Wenn du danach suchst, wirst du jede Menge Sachen auch finden.
Wenn du hier, wenn du hier, keine Ahnung, jetzt nach Frankfurt, 60329.
Ne, ups.
60329.
So, und dann sagst du DevOps und dann scheißen sie dich voll.
Hahaha.
Sinnbildlich gesprochen, ja.
Oje.
Oje, Leute.
Was sehe ich denn da?
Ähm...
The Great Wilhelm ist bei uns ähnlich.
Ist bei uns ähnlich.
Also bei uns ist das reine Administrati...
Reine Administration, äh, gibt's, gibt's in der Art und Weise gar nicht mehr.
Bei uns ist es auch hauptsächlich, äh, äh, Linux, Bash, äh, Puppet, Python.
Das ist lustigerweise sehr, sehr ähnlich zu dem, was wir haben.
Wir haben noch, äh, einige selbst in-house programmierte Java-Anwendungen.
Also fast nur eigentlich.
Und auch dementsprechend alt.
Dann haben wir noch ein paar IBM Rechner.
Wir haben ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen mehr Zeug zusammen.
Wobei ich mich halt hauptsächlich, äh, weniger um die Administrationsgeschichte kümmere.
Zumal ja auch viel bei uns mittlerweile gerade Richtung, äh, in, in, in, in Azure und anderen
Cloud-Geschichten läuft.
Ähm...
Ja, aber ich habe ja ein Video dazu gemacht.
Was, was, was ich mache.
Bezahlt die Deutsche Bahn überhaupt gut?
Keine Ahnung.
Wie gesagt, was, was unterschiedliche Job-Erfahrungen angeht, bin ich der Falsche.
Das sage ich ja auch immer wieder.
Ich war bisher bei zwei verschiedenen Arbeitgebern.
Innerhalb von 15 Jahren oder so.
Also, da, da, da bin ich echt der Falsche, was das angeht.
Äh, macht der Felix nicht bei euch Administrations-Server?
Nee.
Der Felix, der, also der Felix, das ist der, mit dem ich, äh, mal hier die Gamescom-Videos aufgenommen habe.
Weiß gar nicht, ob man das irgendwo noch findet.
Äh, der macht bei uns keine Server-Administration.
Der macht bei uns, ähm, Rechenzentrum.
Und mittlerweile...
Und mittlerweile macht der, äh, ich weiß auch nicht, was mit ihm los ist.
Irgendwelche komischen BWL-Prozesszeug.
Ist der Felix auch der, mit dem ihr das Rechenzentrum-Videos machen wollt, machen wolltet?
Ja, wir haben das Rechenzentrum-Video ja schon aufgenommen.
Aber wir haben noch nichts drüber gelabert.
Seit vier Monaten oder so.
Nee.
Sechs Monaten, sieben Monaten.
Hä, ja.
So sieht's aus.
Der Felix ist auch echt auf der falschen Bahn, BWL-Zeug.
Äh, okay.
Also, ich wollte mal den Kram hier ausprobieren.
MySpaghetti.
Hast du eine Meinung zu Data-Science-Jobs?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Wie probieren wir den Kram denn hier jetzt aus?
Ich bin da ein bisschen zwiegespalten.
Ich würde das ungern...
Wir probieren das in der Windows-VM aus.
Wir haben doch eine Windows-VM gemacht.
Allerdings, Leute, wird das eklig werden.
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen.
Weil...
Die Windows-VM...
Da müssen...
Oh, nee.
Da müssen wir nested virtualisieren.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Nested Virtualisierung mit VirtualBox in VMware Workstation.
Oh, das wird ja was.
Okay, erst mal ausschalten.
Erst mal ausschalten und nested Virtualisierung einschalten.
Weil sonst funktioniert's schon mal gar nicht.
Aber da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Wo war das hier?
Nested Virtualisierung einschalten.
Hier.
Nee.
Da.
Äh, nee.
Moment.
Das da.
Das braucht man, glaube ich, für nested Virtualisierung.
Ich habe ja meine Zweifel, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Hat Windows jetzt nicht auch so ein eingebautes Virtualisierung-Symbol...
Doch.
Irgendwie Zen...
Box oder so?
Weiß gar nicht, wie das so genau heißt.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
VirtualBox.
Hallo, ich will das kopieren.
Ich darf nicht kopieren.
Excellent.
Okay.
Trends.
GitHub.
Es war ganz oben in den Trends.
Ja.
MySpaghetti.
Kannst du kurz mal erläutern, warum man sich vor allem bei Workstation kaufen sollte,
welche Vorteile es hat?
Du kannst beides verwenden.
VirtualBox ist auch nicht schlecht.
Gerade dafür, dass es kostenlos ist.
Ich finde, dass Workstation von der Bedienung her schöner ist.
Und ich finde auch, dass Workstation problemloser funktioniert.
Und auch regelmäßige Updates bekommt.
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass VirtualBox spätestens seit der Oracle-Übernahme so ein bisschen auf Sparflamme läuft.
Aber VirtualBox geht genauso klar.
Es gibt auch einen kostenlosen Forever Player.
Also der Forever Player selbst kostet mittlerweile was.
Aber es gibt einen Forever Player Lite oder sowas.
Der ist kostenlos.
So.
Also.
Was müssen wir jetzt machen?
Äh.
Das Shell-Script.
Testen wir mal.
Windows Subsystem for Linux.
Okay.
WSL installieren.
Excellent.
Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Install WSL 2.
Wir brauchen.
Ne.
WSL 2 geht dann nicht, oder?
Was ist.
Okay.
Was installieren wir da jetzt überhaupt?
Store.
Ach stimmt.
Über Store muss man alles installieren.
Okay.
So.
Hier ist es.
Okay.
Bestimmt.
Über Store muss man einfach Ubuntu suchen.
Ne.
So war das doch irgendwie.
Hello.
Get.
No, thanks.
Install.
Die versuchen dich überall zu Chebaten mit so einem Kack Microsoft Account.
Ey.
Piss dich all du!
Launch.
Okay, also
Was?
Please enable and try it again
Ach stimmt, Moment
Microsoft Logik
Feature
Managing Features
Ne, Moment, wie ging das?
Das war voll versteckt
Das war voll versteckt, WSL
Aktivieren App and Features
Ah, wie ging das nochmal?
Control Pen, machen wir das alte mal auf
Feature
Ah, hier
Warum ist Windows eigentlich
so dumm?
Mit diesem alten und neuen Geschiss
Ey, das ist so unfertiger
Müll
So, äh
Wo ist es denn?
Das da braucht man
Reset, excellent
Die machen das
Das machen die, dass die alte Scheiße
nicht kaputt geht, ja
Aber was ich nicht verstehe ist
Warum sie es nicht schaffen
Das neue zumindest
Ansatzweise Feature gleich mit dem alten hinzukriegen
Weil dann müsstest du
Wenigstens im Frontend nicht mehr rumklicken
Im alten
So wäre der Loading Screen geiler, das stimmt
Wir müssen eigentlich Pause Champ haben
Im Chat
Ja
So, jetzt hier
Eine Runde mal Ubuntu starten
Was gibt es hier zu bestaunen?
Äh, wir probieren gerade das hier aus
Mac OS
Installieren in Virtualbox
Allerdings, weil ich mein Windows System
Damit nicht verschandeln will
Probieren wir das in VMA Workstation
Mit Nested Virtualisierung aus
Was wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren wird
VMA auf der SSD
Ja, ja, ja
VMA ist auf der SSD
Enter new Unix Name
KW
Was?
Wie KW ist nicht erlaubt als Name?
Warum nicht?
Sauerei
Ah gut, Test
Ah, Test geht
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6
Perfekt
Update
Erstmal gleich die richtigen Sachen
Und die wichtigen Sachen hier machen
Achso, Sudo
Ah, yes
Ok, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Das wird, ich sag euch doch
Das wird der komplette Reinfall mit Nested Virtualisierung
Aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob es klappt
Also, was muss man machen?
Einfach nur ausführen, oder?
Ah hier, Dependencies
Dependencies
Ok, wir müssen Virtualbox installieren
Was machen wir?
Wir installieren MacOS in der VM
Also, wget
Zack
Ok, MacOS
Also, ja, ja, ausführbar machen ist gut
MacOS
Wow, mal gucken, ob das überhaupt jetzt was macht
Ok, ich mach mal kurz den Text
Ah, Windows
Please, Edit
Moment, wie macht man hier größer?
Properties, Font
Ja, 28
Excellent
Ähm
Musst du nicht das Skript unter Windows ausführen?
Mach ich ja
Also, was? Das Skript
Oh, fuck, haben wir überhaupt groß genug auf der Festplatte?
Monka
Das könnte knapp werden
Habe ich überhaupt genug Platz?
Ahhhh
Ok, was kann man löschen?
Wir müssen mal kurz Platz machen
Ich kann die VM einfach verschieben
Also, wenn man nichts finden kann, kann ich die VM einfach verschieben
Ist kein Problem
Ähm
Warte mal, wir haben doch hier bestimmt jede Menge Mist rumliegen, was man nicht braucht
Guck mal hier!
3 GB auf dem fucking Desktop
Elementary OS Stable
Weg
Video.mp4
Irgendein
Irgendein Modern Warfare Beta Video
Who cares? Weg
Meme Board Copy, brauchen wir nicht
Windiestat, ja wollte ich eigentlich machen, aber
Wir können es ja mal nachinstallieren
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind
Microsoft, so geht Paketmanager
Nicht wie euer komischer Paketmanager da
Ok, was auch immer
der für Schmerzen hat
Ok
So, mal gucken, wo wir das Zeug deinstallieren können
Ich könnte Modern Warfare deinstallieren
Aber ich glaube Modern Warfare ist gar nicht mehr auf C drauf
Liegt das auch nichts?
Wahrscheinlich nicht
Hoffe ich mal nicht
Ok, solange das hier rummacht
Wir können den ja schon mal anfangen lassen
Wir lassen den schon mal anfangen
Press Enter
Ok
Also, was für eine VM kriegen wir?
Default, wir lassen alles Default
Was?
Make sure following packages are installed
Ok
Upt install
Gezip
Unzip
XXD Wget
Und was? Core Utils
Ok, machen wir
XXD ist glaube ich ein Hex Editor
Yes, yes
Can't, was? Can't find
Ah
Wir müssen Virtual Box von Hand installieren
Das macht er nicht für uns
Virtual Box Download
Dann hast du die VM aber unter WSL, oder?
Ja, macht ja nichts
Äh
Windows Hosts
Megaman Musik hört man einfach raus
So
Wo gibt es das Extension Pack?
Brauchen wir noch
Ok, installen wir das ganze mal
Next
Äh
Mach
, mach
Warning
Yes, excellent, weiter
Yes, genau
So, was, wow, was sagt meine Festplatte?
Also
Manjaro VMs
Alles, alles VMs, Leute
Die kann man nicht wegschmeißen
Ah
Windows ISOs
Alles weg damit
Hä? Äh
Warum sortiert der den
Was ist das für eine?
Ah
Windows
Windows, ich will es einfach nur sortieren
Ich will es einfach nur nach Size sortieren
Windows, warum geht sowas nicht?
Ach, Windows, please
Ok, Grooveby
Name, ne
Kann ich Grooveby nicht einfach ausmachen?
Ah
Ah, none
Zulull
Weg
Excellent, jetzt haben wir Platz, was?
Was?
Ah
Kann es sein, dass wir das noch
Das ist eher
Super Mario Galaxy Bowser Musik, oder?
Ja, haha
Excellent
Was haben wir ansonsten noch hier schönes?
Page, was?
Was ist denn Install ESD?
Das ist irgend so ein Windows Geschiss
Ok, jetzt haben wir schon ein bisschen
Mehr Platz, ich glaube
Damit kommen wir aus
Wenn nicht, verschiebe ich es einfach auf die andere
Es wird jetzt reichen
Das liegt nicht an Windows, das liegt am Anwender
Es liegt immer an zwei Leuten
Es liegt einmal am Anwender
Natürlich, weil er nicht weiß, wie es geht
Aber es liegt am Hersteller
Des UIs, des dem Anwender
So begreiflich wie möglich zu machen
ESD ist das Encrypted Update Image
Aha
Ah, yes
Was hast du für ein Rechner?
8700K
Also wenn du es genau wissen willst
Ah
Ja
8700K, 1080Ti
Mittlerweile 32 GB RAM
Aber der Rest ist noch das gleiche
Yes
Ah, da ist es
Ok, und wie hat man jetzt die
Die Extras
Hier installiert?
Das war doch so ein bisschen
Ah, ok
Ah, gut, jetzt ist es installiert
Yes, yes
Please install
DMG to Image
Ok
Mach mal alles, mach mal alles, kein Problem
Du kannst aber schnell lesen
Ich akzeptiere das einfach
Ähm
Yes
Oh, er macht was
Oh, es lädt Sachen von Apple
So, mal gucken, was die Festplatte so sagt
Vielleicht
Ha, es könnte echt
Es könnte echt eng werden, vielleicht müssen wir die Festplatte vergrößern
Hat jemand
Hat es jemand schon mal gemacht in letzter Zeit
Eine Windows Platte vergrößert
Das müsste mit VMware relativ einfach gehen
Einfach ausschalten, größer machen
Und gut ist
Schauen wir mal
Ich hätte einen Snap
Oh, oh, oh, Leute, wichtig
Ich muss den Snapshot löschen
Der wird sonst unnötig
Groß
Der Snapshot muss weg
Muss die Platte nicht neu partitioniert werden
Ja, aber ich glaube das geht mittlerweile relativ einfach
Ja, mal gucken
Es kann sein, dass es nicht geht
Dann machen wir es einfach nochmal mit vergrößerter Platte
Das wird jetzt nicht so lange dauern
Ich glaube das wird echt ein bisschen
Ein bisschen knapp
Ich meine, der lädt jetzt hier gerade anscheinend das
Das Mac OS ISO runter
Oder was meint ihr, sollen wir gleich die Platte vergrößern
Vielleicht
Ersparen wir uns dann das doppelt
Das doppelt zu machen
Lieber gleich machen, ok
Macht der das, lädt der das eigentlich doppelt dann runter
Ah
Sehr gut
Der macht das doppelt, ok gut
Ähm
Ah, die runtergeladenen Sachen
Behält er aber, oder wie, oder was
Ach da
Das liegt jetzt nicht ernsthaft
Irgendwie im Heimatverzeichnis
Oder so
Ah ne, .exe muss man ja da schreiben, ne
Ok, dann, dann
Machen wir erstmal aus
So
Und erweitern den Kram hier
So, wie macht man das jetzt
Habe ich
Weiß gar nicht, ob ich das überhaupt schon mal gemacht habe
Expand
Boah, easy
Sagen wir mal 60, ja
Ich meine, wir haben halt nicht so wahnsinnig Platz hier
Vielmehr auf
70, 70
Expand
Ich habe nicht so viel Platz
Und hier auch nicht
Wobei hier
Kann ich meine Cod-Aufnahmen wegschmeißen
Was macht der eigentlich
Einen Defragmentieren-Knopf da
Jaja, ich habe noch genug SSDs
Wir könnten theoretisch
Theoretisch könnte ich einfach eine
Eine SSD anschließen per USB
Und wir könnten es damit machen
Würde auch funktionieren, also wir haben auf jeden Fall
Genug Speicherplatz
Und es muss eine SSD sein, sonst dauert es zu lang
Expandigen
Mein Brain expandet auch
Wenn ich diesen Fortschrittsbalken sehe
Ich habe nicht nur einen Terabyte im System
Ich habe
512G
Root
Und zweimal 512G
Das ist nämlich eine Terabyte-Platte, aber das eine ist verschlüsselt
Das habe ich jetzt hier nicht gemountet
Weil ich streame, da ist privates Zeug drauf
So, ist er jetzt fertig?
Ah ja
Excellent
So, Chat
Ich brauche jetzt eure
Eure harten, krassen
Windows-Skills
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, wie das geht
Unter Windows, die Platte zu resizen
Wahrscheinlich muss ich irgendwie in diesen
Disk Manager
Hier, das da
Das ist auf Englisch, Leute
So, hier
Extend
Wow, OKS
Einfach weiter?
Ok, das ist genau so einfach wie
In XFS
In X4 oder Linux zu resizen
Da haben sie aufgeholt
Ok, dann können wir jetzt wirklich
Den anderen Kram machen
Wie viel Platz haben wir jetzt?
Ah, excellent, jetzt haben wir genug
Ja
Jubantu
Yes
Es wird eh nicht funktionieren
Oh fuck
Ich habe doppelt Yes gedrückt
Das mag er bestimmt nicht
Jubantu
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
Ach, guck mal
Der macht wirklich an der gleichen Stelle weiter
Wo wir vorher aufgehört haben
Das finde ich sehr, sehr nice von ihm
MacOS in einer VM-VM
Ja, so sieht es aus
Ich habe nämlich keine Lust
Da mein Windows-PC damit zu verschandeln
Was ist das für eine Leitung?
Ich hoffe, der Stream laggt jetzt nicht
Äh, das ist
Ab
Wenn ich nicht falsch liege
Äh, Kelmore schreibt
Ich hatte mal ein virtualisiertes Windows
Einen virtualisierten Windows-Container
In einer Windows-VM, die via KVM
QEMO auf Linux läuft
Ja, das ist aber auch
Ähm, auch nur doppelt nestet
So wie wir auch haben
Oder?
Mein Windows-Container ist ja Hyper-V
Also sprich, du hast quasi ein Windows in KVM
Und darin hast du nochmal eine Windows-VM gemacht
Das ist quasi die gleiche
Nestet-Virtualisierungstiefe, die wir auch haben
Es wird, es wird
Also, ich habe mal in den Bedenken
Ob es überhaupt funktioniert
Und wenn es funktioniert, wird das heftig langsam sein
Äh
Vodafone
Aber kann ich nicht empfehlen
Äh, Sibaro, das stimmt
Da stand, dass die VM mit 80 GB angelegt wird
Aber normalerweise ist es ja so
Dass VM-Platten nur
Quasi mit 0 starten
Die sehen zwar für die VM nach 80 GB aus
Aber füllen sich erst mit der Zeit
Ich glaube nicht, dass die quasi das komplett
Äh, provisionen
Auf 80G
Dann habe ich natürlich gelitten, weil dann ist es vorbei
Warum downloaden wir
Eigentlich Catalina
Warum, warum downloaden wir nicht
Mo, Mohevi
Oder wie es heißt
Oder, oder, wie heißt denn eigentlich das aktuelle
Ähm
Mac OS
Ach, ist Catalina das aktuelle
ach so habe ich nichts gesagt jaja chat ist ja gut ich hab's verstanden
es muss ja erst mal wieder eine halbe stunde erklärt werden so nach dem
oder max hat ist doch das neue warum weißt du nicht dass das neue mac os 1
muss man ihn ja lassen hübsche sachen machen sie
ich bin ja normalerweise total allergisch dagegen wenn webseiten mein
main main scrollverhalten im browser hijacken
aber hier stört mich gar nicht so sehr habe ich euch eigentlich erzählt dass
ich neues maus tastatur setup habe ich habe jetzt eine pro wireless ja so eine
und ein mauspad
es ist nicht so und das da die zwei sachen habe ich mir geholt habe ich seit
gestern angeschlossen und ich muss sagen wir haben gestern schon noch ein
bisschen wasser und gespielt ich muss sagen die maus ist fast eins zu eins wie
meine g 403 die ich vorher hatte das mausrad fühlt sich ein bisschen anders
an aber das mauspad ich finde das material
unabhängig davon dass das die technik kann ich gleich was zu sagen ziemlich
cool ist aber das material vom mauspad oben von von diesem stoff das gefällt
mir richtig gut im vergleich zu dem alten was ich hatte
es könnte ein bisschen besser verarbeitet sein das mauspad muss ich
sagen also die ränder sind nur verklebt und nicht vernäht das heißt das musste
austauschen wahrscheinlich nach einem jahr das macht nichts aber weil man hat
schon mal ein ersatz mauspad dabei und da gibt es wahrscheinlich auch neuere
dann dann für also ich kann hier ohne problem mit dem daumen an einer stelle
schon ein bisschen das mauspad hochheben so was ja vorher hatte hat ein rocket
hero mauspad so und das gute
an dem mauspad ist keine dauerwerbesendung einfach nur weil ich
mir gerade gekauft haben das gute dem mauspad ist das lädt die maus auf also
sprich das ist eine kabellose maus man muss die maus einfach nur drauf stehen
lassen ich zeige es euch mal da muss sie einfach nur drauf stehen lassen und es
funktioniert so voll geladen sieht jetzt aber nicht aus oder also angeblich lädt
das mauspad die maus kann das sein dass ich das falsch gemacht habe
da war nämlich noch so ein ding dabei lädt das ganze mauspad die maus ich habe
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert ich dachte man muss es einfach drauf stellen
und gut ist doch doch das geht mit der pro wireless schiebt die maus mal nach
oben links und jetzt du musst unten in der maus noch was einbauen genau das
habe ich mir gedacht das steht aber nirgendwo da ist so ein ding dabei für
die maus
oh was geht denn hier jetzt ab?
monkaS
ist das mal ein mac os?
ist das mal ein mac os was schon gestartet ist?
wtf?
äh was?
starting this should take a...
if booting fails see the documentation for information what apply different CPU Profiles
fällt das?
ist das jetzt gefällt oder nicht?
das das heißt das heißt wir machen einfach nichts oder?
ahhhh hier ich glaube der braucht einfach noch ein bisschen
ja da ist er!
ist es vielleicht die ganze Firma?
äh ja will ich mal nachhören
da ist einfach langsam naja nested virtualisierung okay leute ich probiere
das gerade mal nebenbei aus ich mache jetzt mal in meine maus dieses komische
ding rein was dabei war und dann gucke ich mal ob das lädt
da ist nämlich so ein ding zum in die maus klipsen dabei ob das dann
funktioniert ok aufmachen aufmachen und das klipsen wir jetzt mal rein und
woran sie exzellent so geht das also jetzt sagen das muss man ja auch mal
gesagt werden oder das muss einem ja auch gesagt werden und jetzt leuchte das
oben links auch in weiß kann ich das logo ausschalten das logo nervt mich wie
kann ich das logo ausschalten gibt es nicht logo ausschalten ist nicht feste
farbe
naja es leuchtet immer noch es leuchtet ganz dunkel warum gibt es da keinen
knopf ausmachen was ist das schon wieder für ein schwachsinn alter ich ist es
jetzt aus also hundertprozentig aus ist es nett jetzt das leuchtet vor allem die
die auflade led unten leuchtet noch das irritiert mich weil bei der maus geht
das bei der maus kann ich einfach sagen logo aus und gut ist jetzt logo an jetzt
logo aus
das ist total easy aber im aus pet destiny
die völker daof ich hab zum ersten mal hatte ich noch nie vorher ein perl
plätze und komplett ist logiteCH setup mit Logitech maus Tastatur und Logitech
maus pet confirmed
was macht unter m lekke es sie funktioniert
jetzt mal ernsthaft chat chat chat frage frage habt ihr damit gerechnet dass das
einfach so jetzt geht also ich nett ja
zwar klar okay language ich es geht leute für das dass es nested
virtualisiert ist es geht ja es ist jetzt das können schlimmer sein muss ich
jetzt da was machen hier please do not interact wenn mac os
utility window ist ready es macht dinger guck mal da ist das das utility window
ja ok enter okay leute ich mache mal kurz diesen diesen geschiss hier oben
weg
ich habe habe ich da gerade interagiert mit der vm war oder war das das ding ist
es kaputt ist jetzt kaputt fuck ich hab da was okay und wenn wir müssen wir
müssen das fixen wir müssen das fixen wir müssen das krebs fixen
a vor und zurück taste geht nicht wie kommt man an start wie kommt man an
start leute wie kommt man hier anstatt was ist das shortcut im terminal dass
ich unter mac os dass ich ja anfang an
zeile komme pros ein disney puß ein es geht nicht darum ich habe pause 1 und
ende aber das macht es das geht nicht ob und klick an dich echt was ist was
ist ob auf der normalen pc tastatur okay ja ich habe es kaputt gewann was
solltet natürlich skripten was wollte der hier es kreppen
ね
kratzen
ok
Warum musste ich da jetzt auch dran rumfummeln?
Not
Not find
Discs. Okay.
Äh.
HO. Echo.
Then Echo.
Ah.
Excellent. Okay.
Wie komme ich hier an den Anfang?
Das dauert ja 30 Stunden, bis ich da bin, ey.
Okay.
Joichel, danke schön für den Sub.
Poggers.
Control A?
Ah, der Chat.
Au, ja.
Big Brains, der Chat.
Eleven Head.
Okay.
Gleich haben wir es.
Ich, den Bash-Hotkey
verwende ich normalerweise nicht.
Ich mache das meistens mit POS 1.
Okay.
Then Echo.
Echo. Stimmt das jetzt?
Okay.
Ich mache jetzt nichts, Leute.
Ah, wir haben es gefixt.
Wir haben es ganz gemacht.
Wir haben es ganz gemacht, Leute.
Noch mehr.
Joichel, jetzt geht es aber ab.
Zwei Habos verschenkt. An wen denn?
An den Baumi1337?
Nee. Nee, der Baumi hat auch so abonniert.
Huge. Dankeschön.
Hab ich gar nicht gesehen, zwischen den ganzen Subs.
Moment, ich muss mal die andere Maus holen,
dass ich meine Main-Maus-Dings
hier nicht anfassen muss gerade.
Ähm.
Joichel hat zwei Stück verschenkt.
Und zwar an iGamble0.
Excellent.
Ah.
Die Maus spackt rum.
Ah, ich darf rausklicken. Okay, alles gut.
Ähm.
Genau, also, wann haben wir hier den?
An iGamble0 hat er einen verschränkt.
Und an
LevantinLinks.
Zwei Stück.
Huge.
Hexo-Subscription. Dankeschön.
Und der Baumi hat auch so gesubbt.
Nice. Jetzt geht es aber ab.
Wir müssen eigentlich danach, Leute,
wieder eine Runde, ähm,
Substand-Raten machen.
Ich guck mal selbst gerade.
Bei wie vielen Subscribern wir jetzt sind.
Oh, Leute, es ist weniger geworden
als das letzte Mal.
MonkaS.
Na, so viel wie, SeriousMax, so viel weniger
ist es auch nicht geworden.
Nein. Guck mal, Leute, das letzte Mal waren es doch 205.
Das sind jetzt nicht auf einmal,
auf einmal 150.
Es ist ein bisschen weniger.
Als das letzte Mal.
Okay, also.
Was muss ich machen?
Please manually shut down
Virtual Machine and press enter to continue.
Wie?
Shut down.
Nee.
Sleeping Chris, dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, Machine.
Äh, kann man die nicht irgendwie hart
ausschalten?
Wow, okay.
Machine.
Kann man dem nicht sagen?
Hier, mach einfach aus.
Weil das wird ja nicht funktionieren.
Einfach Power off.
Das ist nicht das Richtige.
Das ist Powerknopf drücken.
Ich will einfach ausschalten.
Knopf.
Hier.
Bam.
Enter.
Okay.
Ah, da geht's weiter.
Alles klar.
Oh, das sieht nicht gut aus, oder?
Oder doch?
Doch, doch, okay.
Sieht normal aus.
Ob Stecker ziehen so gut war?
Oh, das stand da.
Das stand da, dass ich das machen soll.
Okay, ich muss grad mal den Kram da oben wieder wegmachen.
Das nervt.
Leute, das Scam-Train ist am Start.
Er fährt.
Vergleich zur Bahn.
Ja, Leute, wenn euch der Content gefällt und ihr noch einen freien Prime-Sub habt
und ihr wollt den Chat-IQ weiter ins Unermessliche steigern.
Any Primers?
Dann können wir den Hype-Train vielleicht noch auf Stufe 3 fahren lassen.
ZF-Chris, Anno-Score, dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Es geht aufwärts, ich seh's ja.
Poggers, dankeschön für den Sub.
Also, wir haben noch zwei Minuten Zeit, um auf Level 3 zu kommen.
Da gibt's auch extra Emotes.
Wenn man Glück hat.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie die Mechanik genau funktioniert.
Ilo.
1706, drei Monate, wupp, wupp.
Nice Subscription.
Subscription.
Und Game HQ 702.
Was ist es mit den Zahlen in den Usernames hier gerade?
Aber Stufe 2 abgeschlossen.
Der Hype-Train ist am Start.
Dankeschön für den Sub, Game HQ.
Dafubi, sechs Monate.
Poggers.
Jetzt geht's aber los, ja.
Die Primers sind wieder am Start.
Und alle gucken zu, wie MacOS versucht, irgendwie nested virtualisiert zu booten.
Ja.
Mal kurz gucken, wie viele Subs wir jetzt haben.
Wir machen nachher zum Schluss noch wieder ein Sub-Giveaway.
Ich muss mir mal was besseres überlegen, wie die Abonnentenzahl raten.
Das ist eigentlich langweilig.
Wir müssen irgendein...
Wir müssen irgendein Big Brain...
...Abo-Giveaway machen.
Irgendwas, wo man zeigen kann, dass man hier...
...was im Kopf hat.
Da kann ich dir was schicken.
Ja, sie war auch eine gute Idee.
Wenn du eine gute Idee hast, schieß los.
Ausgaben von Kack-Programmen erraten.
Geo-Kunzer-Body-Pillows.
Da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht dran gedacht.
Vivo Still, das ist gut.
10++ to Upper-Programmieren ohne Copy-Paste.
Das ist nice.
Das Problem ist, dass die Leute einfach googeln können danach.
Okay, also.
Jetzt geht weiter.
Geht weiter.
Please enter when language window is ready.
Is ready.
When utilities window is ready.
Okay, müssen wir warten.
Bis das Utility-Window ready ist.
Okay, weiter. Weiter geht's.
Weiter.
Press enter when terminal prompt is ready.
Yes.
Okay, es gibt wieder hier Big Brain.
Hacker-Kommandozeilen-Action.
Ja, ich tipp jetzt nix, Leute.
Ich hab die Hände oben.
Ich tipp jetzt nix.
Wie, fertig?
Ist es jetzt fertig?
Ich hab das schon gesehen, was im Terminal steht.
Aber ich dachte mir, der sagt jetzt noch irgendwas hier im Skript.
That's it.
Enjoy your virtual machine.
Okay, dann warten wir mal ab.
Dann warten wir mal ab.
Was mache ich?
Abonniert zwei Monate.
Excellent.
Dankeschön.
Huge Subscription.
Oh, Hype Train ist vorbei, Leute.
Huge.
Massive Subscriptions.
Chat, ich muss euch mal loben, jetzt nicht, weil so viele Subs gekommen sind, das finde ich auch nice, ja, aber wie aktiv mein Chat immer ist, das muss ich, muss ich echt mal, muss ich echt mal sagen, das ist echt nice, ja, ich meine, 214 Zuschauer, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es wenig wäre, es gibt genug auf Twitch, die sich wahnsinnig drüber freuen würden, wenn sie 214 Zuschauer hätten, keine Frage, aber es ist auch weit entfernt von wirklich irgendwelchen riesen, riesen Chats, ja, und die Aktivität hier im Chat ist wirklich, ähm,
da hab ich gar kein E-Mail für.
Ja, das hier vielleicht noch am besten, ja, also der Chat ist wirklich unglaublich aktiv und was, was ich echt bemerkenswert finde, was ich in keinem anderen Chat, außer in meinem Chat, äh, sehe ist, dass die Leute hilfreiche Sachen schreiben.
Vorhin, wo ich keine Ahnung hatte, was ich in der Konsole drücken muss, STRG A, sofort einer im Chat gesagt, ja, ich meine, ich kriege sogar Pokimane Subs gegiftet.
Also, ich meine, besseren Chat.
Chat kann es, kann es ja nun mal wirklich nicht geben, äh, Big Brain Chat, ja, und mit jedem Sub, ihr wisst es, Leute, mit jedem Sub wird der Chat IQ noch höher.
Also, wir sind jetzt ja schon ganz weit vorne.
Also, wenn man mal, so, wenn man mal einen Chat, Chat IQ Level hätte, ja, dann sind wir wahrscheinlich mit unserem Durchschnitts-Chat IQ schon mindestens mal an XQC vorbeigezogen, weil XQC hat zwar viele Zuschauer,
Zuschauer.
Allerdings.
Allerdings, die meisten Leute sind halt, äh, recht Low Brain, ja, wobei hier der Anteil der Big Brain Leute einfach, äh, richtig, richtig hoch geht immer.
Wobei ich ja nichts sagen darf, ich gucke ja XQC selber ab und zu.
Aber die meisten sind einfach wirklich, äh, ziemlich dämlich.
Und ich glaube, Montana Blacks Chat zum Beispiel kann man das Durchschnitts-IQ Level gar nicht bestimmen, weil, ähm, unter 18 ist das, ist das, äh, immer, kann man das nicht gut, kann man das nicht gut bestimmen.
Und nachdem der Montana Black Chat wahrscheinlich zu 95% irgendwie 14-Jährige sind, geht das nicht.
Äh, Levantin links geht mir ähnlich.
Der, äh, ich geht mir ähnlich, ich gucke auch keinen deutschen Streamer.
Ich hab, habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Ich hab's nur so am Rande verfolgt.
Ja, jetzt wurde der Kram da gerade inszeniert.
Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Ähm, irgendwie mit, mit dem, mit dem Böhmermann-Flame-Montana-Black.
Das ist irgendwie alles.
Rechte sind oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit den Leuten da immer los ist.
Also, das Letzte, wo ich bei Montana Black und irgendwie den Chat dran denken würde, dass das irgendwie Rechte sind, das sind Kinder zum größten Teil.
Ja, offensichtlich.
Das sind zum größten Teil Kinder.
Und, oder sagen wir mal so Jugendliche, Kinder bis Jugendliche.
Und ein paar auch schon Ältere.
Aber, was hat das denn mit Recht?
Das ist doch nicht alles rechts mittlerweile.
Was ist, was ist denn da los?
Das ist, das ist nicht der AfD-Youtube-Channel oder so.
Wobei, selbst da kann man sich über, selbst da kann man sich drüber schreiben, wie rechts das teilweise ist, ja.
Aber gerade bei Montana Black und dem Chat, da würde ich im Leben nicht dran denken.
Also, keine Ahnung, was der Böhmermann für, für, für Schmerzen hat.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach, ähm, einfach nur Gelaber.
Im Endeffekt, die, ähm, das Erste, was ihm einfällt, ist halt quasi, das sind Nazis und Rechts.
Das ist wahrscheinlich die Standardbeleidigung, die da irgendwie rauskommt.
Aber so genau habe ich es irgendwie nicht.
Ich habe nicht verstanden, was der Beef da sollte.
Hast du dir das schon angeschaut?
C-Sharp 9 Features, ja.
Ähm, Mon, oh, das kann ich, kann ich ja auch, was, Mon, äh, Mon Everest.
Mon, Mond Everest.
Oh, das, das riecht nach einem Basics-Witz jetzt im Chat gleich.
Ich sehe es schon, komm.
Äh, funzt das nur in der VM, beziehungsweise, wie ist die Policy von macOS?
Eigentlich sollte das doch nur auf Apple-Geräten funzen.
Ähm, das funktioniert sogar auf Hardware.
Kennst du schon den KLS-Mount-Everest-Song?
Nein, den kenne ich nicht.
Und ich, ich will mir ihn ehrlich gesagt auch nicht anhören.
Weil das Nächste, was dann kommt, ist, wenn ich mir das anhöre,
dass ich mir Haftbefehl, Features, wie heißt die Pew, das ist Shirin, Shirin David oder so, anhören muss.
Und das will ich mir auch nicht anhören.
Auch wenn ich mir ab und zu Haftbefehl, ich will nicht sagen, gerne anhöre, das trifft's nicht.
Aber ab und zu höre ich mir meinen Haftbefehl an.
Aus Gründen.
Aus Gründen, die sich mir selbst nicht ganz erschließen.
Aber manchmal, manchmal, ja, aber das muss ich mir nicht geben.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er aus Frankfurt, eigentlich sind die nicht aus Offenbach.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er aus Frankfurt ist, ja.
Max, hör dir den Song an.
Okay, okay.
Aber nur während der Installation jetzt.
Also, KLS von dem Mount-Everest-Song.
Ich ahne Schlimmes, das wird Paints-Champ, Leute.
Das wird richtig...
Richtig Paints-Champ.
Max hört Deutschrap so gut wie nicht.
Es tut mir jetzt schon weh.
Moment.
Wie lange geht das jetzt noch so?
Drei Millionen Aufrufe, easy.
Oh ne, das Schmerz, das Schmerz, das ist, also, Musik kann wirklich körperliche Schmerzen hervorrufen, und das gehört dazu.
Nein.
Nein, Leute.
Das kann ich mir nicht drei Minuten anhören, das geht nicht.
Nein, Leute. Das kann ich mir nicht drei Minuten anhören, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Ey, ich hör mir, ich hör mir jetzt keine komische YouTube-Meme-Musik an.
Der beste Memesong ist immer noch...
Da gibt's nix.
Bester, bester Memesong.
Da geht nix drüber.
Besser.
Das ist halt mal die richtige Kokona-Musik.
J-Salt and Fail-Fish.
Warum kann...
Warum kann ich die Lyrics eigentlich?
Was nowhere.
Everyone's feeling fine.
Kappa-Pock-Jam.
Kipo-Forehand.
Balbe-Thumb.
Twitchy-Mode.
Moment, wie weit ist die Installation?
65 Prozent, okay.
Far away.
Um die Frage mal was Sinnvolles zu beantworten im Chat,
finde ich,
wenn man fragt,
ja, aber wieso auf VM so easy mit OSX?
Auf Hardware ist ja ein ziemlicher Struggle.
Hat Apple was an ihrer Policy geändert?
Nee.
Ähm,
das ist ein Gitter-Projekt,
was wir gefunden haben,
was quasi das verskriptet,
das was der Struggle ist.
Also verskriptet der Struggle auf,
wow,
auf 1500 Zeilen Shell-Skript.
Deswegen geht das so.
Einfach.
Was steht eigentlich in dem zweiten Terminal?
Ich klicke das jetzt nicht an.
Mit dem KVM-Skript noch wesentlich einfacher und schneller.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen, aber es geht ja hier nicht.
Wie soll ich, soll ich VM, soll ich hier noch ein KVM-Windows in, in Dings machen oder so?
Nee, nee.
AMD-User, das stimmt.
Ups.
Der ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht, ne?
Mega-Upload.
Out, out.
Und der Leute, Kram läuft ja immer noch.
Wie viel Platz haben wir eigentlich noch auf der Platte?
Ah, ah, easy, reicht.
Ich weiß auch, wer Mega-Upload liked.
Die liken bestimmt Mega-Upload auch, wahnsinnig.
Hat's funktioniert, das installiert noch, ist bei 85%.
Oh, er ist fertig.
Siehst du die Emotes auch? Ja, klar.
Deswegen habe ich das ja auch so programmiert, dass ich die Emotes sehe.
Ich, ich, ich.
Die ganzen vorgefertigten Lösungen haben mir aus dem Grund nicht gefallen, weil man die Emotes nicht sieht.
Und ich garantiert immer vergessen würde, die Emotes wieder auszublenden, wenn ich sie selbst nicht sehen würde.
Außerdem brauche ich ein Web-Interface, wo ich den Schwachsinn anklicken kann hier.
Und auch Sound-Support.
Piss dich, Alter.
Upload to me today.
Enemy is the one that's in your world.
Wir haben ja schon sehr viel Schwachsinn gesammelt hier.
Wonka is? Wonk, wonk, wonk.
Was macht das denn jetzt eigentlich so lange?
Ist das jetzt kaputt?
Ist das jetzt kaputt, oder geht das noch?
For free!
Hast du Erfahrung mit Docker? Ja?
Geht so.
Warten, warten. Okay, Chat, ich warte.
Ich warte, ja.
Fass das Hell!
Was willst du denn Dockermäßig wissen, Max Jakob 1?
Das Ding, das geht viel länger, als es sein müsste.
Warum singen die am Ende noch eine Million? Mega! Warum singen die am Ende noch eine Million? Mega!
Mega
Das ist aber das ist aber eine arme Kindheit
Naja das Internet hat damals auch schon gesagt zumindest in Deutschland
Das stimmt schon dass das von 2011 in 1080p ist ist schon Poggers aber Upload Speed hat er ja wohl genug gehabt
Es macht was
Highspeed ja mega nz gibt es ja auch nicht mehr das gehört jetzt irgendwelchen chinesen
In Wirklichkeit chat in Wirklichkeit ist das stimmt das alles nicht was wir hier machen
Das ist ein Livestream von meinem iphone
Das geht schnell das haben wir eine ssd
Haben eine ssd da soll es halbwegs schnell gehen
What are you doing installing mac os inside nested virtualization
Wie am workstation on windows
Inside a windows vm with virtual box for mac os
I
Think it will be completely unusable
Poggers hier als kommt der international stream durchbruch
Sachs euch
Warum betonen iphone nutzer immer dass ein iphone ist und sagen nicht handy wie jeder andere auch
warum
warum musst du veganer nicht fragen ob sie veganer sind
10 minuten
Ich finde handy ich sage übrigens gar nicht mehr handy fällt mir auf also ich sagt so nix mehr handy sagt immer smartphone
Ich sag zu allem ich sag zu einem smartphone was quasi früher handy war
Handy ist auch so ein typisches so typisches deutsches wort kein mensch international verwendet handy
Klingt klingt voll englisch und sonst wie alles verwendet da keiner
Sie sagen ein mobile oder oder smartphone oder sonst was
Phoenix da hast du recht er schreibt besonders ältere leute kennen das wort tablet nicht da ist alles ein ipad das ist das ist aber so eine krankheit
Das haben viele leute
Früher war jede konsole nintendo wenn die wenn die mutter oder der vater nintendo kannte es war jede konsole playstation
Wenn der vater die mutter playstation kannte
Und jetzt sind halt jegliche sachen von tablets sind halt ipads
der chat klar sagen die handy um etwas handliches zu beschreiben
Das war jetzt aber auch so typische chat nachricht einfach mal was zu sagen oder
Mir ist klar dass es das von handy gibt wenn was handy ist aber die sagen nicht zu ihrem smartphone handy
11 core komisch
Weil wsl ist ja auch unter drunter
hast du mal hast du dich mal abgemeldet und wieder angemeldet
Weil gerade unter und du musst du eigentlich gar nichts machen virtual box sollte standardmäßig im passt drin sein da musst du passt nichts anpassen
Du musst kein paar setzen
ok
Als kräuter das habe ich nicht gesehen
Ich glaube apple bietet uns ein bisschen mit der installation dauer
Das entspricht nicht so ganz den tatsachen festplatten speicher haben wir genug
Bei der gelegenheit habe ich noch habe ich noch hier genug festplatten speicher
auch ja also
Mario kart musik excellent schon mal das redesignte wind terminal benutzen ja
Haben wir sogar schon mal im stream ausprobiert
Es ist nicht mehr ganz so schlecht wie das alte her das stimmt
Aber hat immer noch ziemlich viele
Probleme mit irgendwelchen escape sequenzen gehabt die nicht richtig funktioniert haben und so was
Also es wird nach wie vor auch nichts über eine ordentliche linux vm gehen wenn man windows halt hauptsächlich verwenden will
Die pass variablen findest du immer das ist die frau die ist standard gesetzt eleven core weiß ich warum das skript nicht funktioniert das musste also wenn du die befehle ausführen kannst auf der kommandozeile für virtual box dann muss es das skript auch finden hast du das neue elektro boom video schon gesehen wenn du das zu 5g meinst ja das war richtig gut
wind geht
Support
ic wind geht haben wir ausprobiert dazu muss ich dir noch mal kurz den clip
vorspielen aus dem letzten stream
falls wir falls das den clip falls ich den finde der sagt nämlich meine reaktion
los clips wo bloß der sagt nämlich meine meinung
Zu wind get trifft trifft es eigentlich ganz gut
sieben tage
gut warum ist jetzt neue twitch profil so kacke
Ok
also der clip zu wind geht da müsste doch hier irgendwo sein sing fps das von heute
Ja, hallo twitch
Was ist ein install wie lösche ich denn was
install
Gehen
wind get remove
was was
microsoft
Mein kopf war das tut ja weh
warum
Ich habe gerade echt mein kopf ging so plastik ding gekloppt
Also wie man es schafft ein paketmanager zu bauen der sachen nicht installieren kann entzieht sich vollkommen meiner
Meinen auffassungshorizont
Es ist eigentlich nicht möglich so was bescheuert das zu programmieren
Ich finde es gut dass es machen aber dass es nicht wie moven kann ist einfach schon abgrundtiefer fail
Warum heißt du hier eigentlich wo bloß und nicht auf youtube weil ich
Ursprünglich nie vor hatte auf twitch zu streamen und mir einen account erstellt habe wo ich selbst gucken kann und irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht wir fangen jetzt
Einfach an zu streamen und da hieß der account wo bloß max fps habe ich mir irgendwann mal auch gesichert den account habe ich noch irgendwo ich könnte es
Jetzt umbenennen
Aber ich will es gar nicht umbenennen ich finde so eigentlich viel angenehmer
da tut sich nichts hier oder
der der macht nix
Wie lahm der ist neun minuten
Da lockt sich jetzt gerade der apple support mitarbeiter ein und programmiert erst mal mac os fertig
Das ist auch auf hardware so beruhigend zu wissen
Ja es ist halt lahm dank virtualisierung
Also nicht dank virtualisierung sondern dank virtualisierung in virtualisierung
Aber ja ich schon mal gesagt dass ich die den neuen trend zu progress balken die nichts anzeigen außer progress doch finde
Ich finde es immer gut wenn sich was auf bildschirm bewegt oder zumindest irgendwas passiert oder das apple logo hier meinetwegen pulsiert oder oder sich in den kreis dreht oder so einfach dass man sieht da ist nicht abgekackt da macht auch was siehst du ob die vm ressourcen verbraucht überhaupt noch was macht ja kann ich nachgucken ja die macht noch einiges die ist voll am schaffen stimmt wie viel memory haben wir denn
Oh
Oh er hat schon 5g
Die vm hat
Wenn ich das jetzt ausschalte
Geht es dann an der stelle weiter
Wahrscheinlich nicht oder
Die musik gerade was ist das
Ah klar das ist
Ja ja
Ich erinnere mich
5g ist das nicht dieser virus
Oh fuck exposed leute
Also ich hab ja gedacht
Wir schaffen das heute fertig ja
Aber
Ich sag mal so
Ich hab ja gedacht
So in spätestens einer halben stunde muss ich auf
Der wird doch neun minuten in 30 minuten schaffen oder
Oh habt ihr es gesehen
Leute habt ihr es gesehen
Ich hab's ich hab's genau gesehen
Ich hab's ganz genau gesehen
Es hat sich es hat sich bewegt
Es hat sich bewegt ich hab's genau gesehen
Ha ha habt ihr es gesehen
Es ist weiter gegangen
Es macht was
Guckt leute es geht weiter
Ne aber ernsthaft es hat sich eben bewegt
Ähm
Während das installiert
Können wir uns gerade nochmal die anderen Trending Repos auf Github angucken was da gerade so angesagt ist
Ähm
Apple rechnet die Zeit anders
Bei Apple spielt die Zeit keine Rolle
Also was haben wir das probieren wir gerade aus
Will man das
Gibt es da irgendwo ein Beispiel
Demo
Latex now
Ja
Sieht aus wie ein
Wie heißt es jetzt eigentlich richtig
Latex
Olivia
Ah AI Zeugs
Your new best friend
Das stimmt nicht
Mein bester Freund ist der Twitch Chat
Und Prime Subscriber
Prime
Ähm
Was ist das hier Mobile
Technicode Twitch Prime Dankeschön
Excellent
Es hat funktioniert
Ist das ein Personal Assistant oder sowas
Chatbot
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt
Wo wir gerade bei äh äh
Sinslosen Installation
Habe ich euch eigentlich schon erzählt
Wie ich versucht habe
Auf der Arbeit vor einem halben Jahr
Oder so
Einen Fake Chatbot anzupreisen
Weiß nicht
Ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe und zwar
Ähm wir hatten so ein
So ein komisches Projekt wo es um
Um Innovationen ging ja
Und da habe ich vorgeschlagen
Weil unsere
Dokumentation zu Software
Hardware Prozessen
Alles so extrem verteilt ist
Habe ich vorgeschlagen okay
Ähm wir sollten
Da mal eine gemeinsame Datenbank
Basteln und das es so richtig
Hip ist weil ich dachte mir eine gemeinsame
Datenbank die bringt zwar was ist aber nicht
Sonderlich innovativ und hip
Da habe ich halt gesagt okay wir sollten eine gemeinsame
Datenbank machen und
Ähm als Interface
Zusätzlich eine Chatbot anbieten
Und da habe ich mich hingesetzt und habe eine
Chatbot gebastelt der halt komplett
Fake war also sprich
Ich habe eine Webseite gebastelt
Das aussieht wie äh
Eine Skype Konversation weil damals hatten wir
Skype und ähm
Die Leute die haben halt Chat mit Skype verbunden
Ich habe eine Webseite gemacht die aussieht
Wie eine so Skype Chat Chatbox
So ungefähr ungefähr wie eine Skype Chatbox
Und
Dort konntest du dann so Sachen fragen
Wie was gibt es heute zum Mittagessen
Oder oder Dokumentation
Zu XY und sowas
Und natürlich
Natürlich war
Da dahinter
Dahinter
War zwar ein Chatbot
Der war aber so mit
Der konnte nur drei Sachen
Beantworten weil ich den mit
Mit drei Testsätzen gefüttert hatte
Ja und ähm
Dann habe ich noch zum demonstrieren
Dass das was voll geiles ist
Habe ich jetzt halt noch drei vier andere
Sachen eingebaut die er beantworten kann
Ich weiß es
Gar nicht mehr das eine war was es heute zu essen
Gibt was man realistisch gesehen
Tatsächlich ein Chatbot fragen kann
Weil unsere weil die Kantine und die Restaurants
Die haben ja alle haben ja alle äh
Die liefern bei uns ja alle auch Speisekarten ein
Und sonst könnte man ohne Probleme
Da reinbringen
Zumindest im Prinzip war das halt eine Webseite
Mit
Ein paar Ifs
Und als ich das in der
Als wir die Demo gezeigt haben davon
Fanden das alles super geil
Das fanden alle super geil
Die haben halt
Ich habe es ja
Ich habe es der einen sogar noch erklärt
Wie wir es gemacht haben ja
Ich habe gesagt ja da ist wirklich ein Bot dahinter
Aber der ist halt noch nicht gut trainiert
Ähm den Rest haben wir halt
Quasi so gebaut wie es
Dann ist wenn es richtig benutzt wird
Ja also
Im Prinzip habe ich sowas wie Target Render gemacht
Was die quasi in der Spieleprogrammierung
Permanent machen ja
Ich habe das der einen sogar erklärt
Die hat die hat es nicht kapiert
Die waren alle voll begeistert
Also ich habe quasi mehr oder weniger erklärt
Der Bot ist Fake
Natürlich habe ich so nicht gesagt
Sondern ähm halt das das Schöne umschrieben
Und dann haben sie gesagt
Oh ist das eine tolle Geschichte
Genau das stellen wir uns hier unter Innovation vor
Genau das stellen wir uns unter Innovation vor
Ja und es wurde
Oh 8 Minuten Leute es geht aufwärts
Und ähm
Es wurde dann beschlossen
Dass man das Thema
Gemeinsame Klosar
Und gemeinsame Dokumentation
Und halt auch diesen Chatbot
Dass man das weiter verfolgen möchte
Haben sie entschieden
Das war vor einem halben Jahr
Ich habe seit demnächst mal von gehört
Aber wer größere Firmen kennt
Der weiß
Dass die Informationen und gute Vorsätze
Zu hau vorhanden sind
Aber dass die aller aller
Allermeisten Sachen auf dem Weg
Komplett einschlafen
Ich weiß nicht Chat wie es bei euch
Auf der Arbeit aussieht
Aber bei uns ist das Standard
Bei uns ist das Standard
Es wird manchmal so einmal im Jahr
Kommt wieder jemand auf die Idee
Und macht ihr so eine größere Veranstaltung
Nach dem Motto
Ja hier Innovation 2021
Und was gibt es für Ideen
Und dann wird irgendwas gehypt
Und im Endeffekt nie gemacht
Also das ist bei uns Standard
Dass mit sehr viel Elan angegangen wird
Und dann am Ende eigentlich nichts passiert
Aber ganz ehrlich
Who cares
Sollen machen was sie wollen
So lange sie mich bezahlen
Ist mir das wirklich
Also das hat auch eine Weile gedauert
Bis ich auf dem Stand angekommen bin
Dass es so schwachsinnig ist
Was gemacht wird
Quasi im Business
Oder in Enterprise Umgebung
Dass komplett sinnlose Sachen gemacht werden
Dass viel erzählt wird
Und nichts davon umgesetzt wird
Dass die meisten Leute keine Ahnung
Von ihrem Beruf
Beziehungsweise von ihrem Themengebiet haben
Und dass die meisten Leute
Auch extrem schwer von Begriff sind
Wenn man irgendwas sagt
Da habe ich mich schon dran gewöhnt
Aber was sorgt dafür
Dass der Elan schwindet
Da bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher
Ich glaube ja
Dass das folgendermaßen funktioniert
Dass am Ende des Jahres
Die Abteilungs
Und Direktions
Und Gedöns
Und Leiter
Beim Vorstand
Irgendwelche Sachen vorstellen müssen
Quasi Innovation
Und wenn sie das vorgestellt haben
Die hatten nie Interesse
So meine persönliche Vermutung
Dass man nie wirklich Interesse hatte
Was umzusetzen oder was zu ändern
Sondern dass man einfach nur was gebraucht hat
Was man dem Vorstand verkaufen kann
Was man für innovative Pläne hat
Ohne dass man eigentlich was machen will
Zumindest denke ich mir das so
Für meinen Teil
Dass da viel mehr Schein als Sein dabei ist
Aber gerade
Im Finanzbank Umfeld
Könnte ich wetten
Dass das allen mehr oder weniger so geht
Kann man sich als Anwendungsentwickler
Überhaupt einfach als DevOps Engineer bewerben?
Klar
Wenn du die Voraussetzungen für die jeweilige
Position
Alle Voraussetzungen
Erfüllen ist ja eh mittlerweile
Fast utopisch
Aber wenn die
Beispielsweise wollen
Dass du
Automatisierte Software Tests machst
Dass du irgendwelche
Unterstützung
Schnittstelle zwischen
Anwendung und Admins machst
Muss halt gucken ob das passt
Klar kannst du dich da drauf bewerben
Natürlich
Und wie gesagt
Ich habe nichts davon mehr gehört
Oh 6 Minuten Leute
Es geht aufwärts
Wir sind gleich fertig
Ich glaube wir schaffen es doch noch
Bis ich auf muss
Ja und Yemtex
Gerade wenn du mal ein bisschen mit Jenkins
Zum Beispiel rumgebastelt hast
Das ist nicht mehr so angesagt
Das macht man jetzt alles
Was weiß ich über Drone oder Cloud
Irgendeiner Cloud oder irgendwas was auch immer
Aber Jenkins ist schon ganz okay
Ist zwar manchmal ein bisschen abartig zu bedienen
Ähm
Bisschen Versionsverwaltung ist natürlich
Aber da bist du wahrscheinlich als Anwendungsentwickler
Schon ganz gut dabei
Wobei ich sagen muss die meisten unserer
Anwendungsentwickler sind im Umgang mit Git
Nicht gut
Was ich da teilweise für Merchrequests kriege
Beziehungsweise was da teilweise die Leute für komische
Apps machen
Da weiß ich auch nicht
Wo bekommt man eigentlich legal eine MacOS ISO für eine VM her
Da
Skript ausführen
Lädt alles für dich runter und macht
Lädt offiziell von den Apple Servern runter
Und nachdem das off
Boah ich habe schon gedacht es wäre abgekackt
Nachdem das offiziell von Apple Servern runtergeladen wird
Ist kann da ja wohl schlecht was illegales dran sein
Ich musste mich nirgendwo einloggen oder so
Ja ob das legal ist
In Form dass man die TOS
Akzeptiert hat
Naja
Das beste Commit hat mal der Felix gemacht bei uns
Der hat drei Commits gemacht
Da stand Shit Git, Fuck Git und
Leck mich Git oder irgendwie sowas drin
Da war er irgendwie an dem Tag nicht gut drauf
Ja also
Das sind so Sachen klar
Das raubt einem schon ein bisschen die Motivation
Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen
Also sprich wenn man da Sachen vorschlägt
Und man hört gefühlt jahrelang nichts von
Und es tut sich auch nichts
Auf der anderen Seite
Mittlerweile bin ich echt auf dem Stand
Sag ich mir okay
Solange mein Gehalt pünktlich ankommt
Und ich mit dem Umfeld zufrieden bin
Und mit der Kohle die ich dafür kriege
Zufrieden bin
Ist mir die meiste Sache eigentlich vollkommen egal
Ich reg mich da auch über kaum noch was auf
Weil ich habe genug Ausgleich
Für was anderes
Also ich lebe ja irgendwie nicht für die Arbeit
Ich mach das was ich mach so gut ich kann
Und alles andere ist mir mittlerweile vollkommen egal
Das dauert aber ein bisschen
Bis man da sich
Und es ist auch nicht jeder
Es ist auch nicht jeder
Es hat auch nicht jeder so die gleiche Einstellung
Es sieht auch nicht jeder so
Ja
Oh das ist schön was ist das denn
Learn git branching
Oh das ist schick
Das gefällt mir zeige ich mal her
Welcome learn git branching
Und wie geht das jetzt
Achso
Okay machen wir mal Mixed Back
Achso ich hätte das lesen müssen
Dass ich checke was ist
Goal to reach
Only master branch will be checked in this level
Ich hätte mir durchlesen sollen
Was ich machen sollte
Soll ich commits zusammenfassen
Oder was soll ich machen
Only the master branch
So the other branches are simply reference
Ich soll die Dinger hier zu einem fix zusammenfassen
Oder wie
Was soll da am Ende rauskommen jetzt
Und wie tippt man hier was ein
Ah hier unten
Was hat er gesagt jetzt schau
Ah cool
Ähm
Ne
Ich soll die commits zusammenfassen oder wie
Also wenn ich das machen soll dann ist es relativ
Relativ
Easy
Ich bin auf dem
Bugfix branch ja
Gut weil man git lock
Dann suchen wir uns das commit raus als
Oh fuck das lässt sich nicht richtig bedienen
Oh
Äh
Wtf
Ist das jetzt alles was da drin ist oder nicht
Ok äh
Dann brauchen wir hier C2
Wollen wir haben
Wo ist die commit id
Ist die commit id C2
Normalerweise ist das ein langer hash wert
Ok also ich hab leider nicht durch gelesen
Ich hab leider nicht durch gelesen
Was man eigentlich machen soll
Ja
Genau jetzt haben wir den git status
Jetzt ist der ganze kram un commit
Macht das wirklich was es machen soll
POG
Hä
Das macht irgendwie nicht das was es machen soll
Normalerweise hätte das jetzt ein commit
Aus den beiden machen müssen
Das stimmt nicht
Ok dann müsste ich mir durch lesen was man machen soll
Dann müsste ich mir durch lesen was man machen soll
Aber das ist
Das merke ich mir auf jeden fall
Das ist ne richtig gute sache
Das muss ich mir unbedingt aufschreiben
Ähm
Kann ich nämlich mal meinen leuten auf der arbeit echt schicken
Äh
Keine Ahnung
Merken
Ähm
Also ich mach da einfach nen rebase interactive
Und schieb alles in einen commit
Ich weiß nicht
Ich hab mich grad verdrückt
Ich hab grad irgendwas
Irgendwas gelöscht
Äh
Ich hab dich grad aus Versehen gesperrt
Das war keine Absicht
Ähm ich hab einfach in den chat gedrückt und da war grad das
Löschensymbol
Maunks
Äh wie anbänd man jemand
Ah na serious
Max hat schon gemacht
Maunks alter
Also ja genau
Das ist gut
Das merke ich mir mal
Das merke ich mir das ist echt nice
Das schick ich den leuten morgen mal
Und
Und am besten
Mach ich in teams irgendwie ne umfrage
So nach dem motto
Bitte innerhalb von einer Woche
Bestätigen das man es erledigt hat
Irgendwie sowas
Richtig fies
Irgendjemand hat grad was gefragt
Vorhin
Also ich mach da einfach nen rebase interactive
Und schieb alles in einem commit mit fix ab
Also ich mach meistens kein interactive rebase
Kann man auch machen
Aber wenn das so
Alter haben wir das heute nochmal
Aber wenn das ne branch ist wo nur ich was dran mache
Und die commits kommen alle hintereinander
Dann mach ich ein reset
Und ein neues commit
Und gut es kommt aufs gleiche raus
Ein rebase macht ja unter der haube
Ähm
Genau das gleiche
Ein rebase macht auch ein reset
Und ne schleife
Mit cherrypicks hintereinander
Also ein rebase könnte man
Also git rebase könntest du nachbauen
Ohne probleme mit 3 zeilen shell script
4 zeilen shell script
Ich mach meistens lieber nen reset
Und ähm
Dann ne neues commit
Aber das ist das geschmackssache
Das schöne bei git ist ja dass du
Die meisten sachen auf 20 verschiedenen
Wegen machen kannst so wie es gerade am besten passt
Oder wie es dir am liebsten ist
Nur noch 5 minuten
Ja genau wir haben 45 angefangen
Da waren es nur noch 7 minuten
Ähm
Wo ich grad beim
Geschichten
Aus dem paulaner garten
Am erzählen bin
Wir machen 7
Twitch prime
Excellent
Subscription
Dankeschön
Ähm
Hatte ich euch schonmal die sache erzählt
Wo uns der
Obervorstands
Gründungschef Mensch
Besucht hat also quasi der
Oberguru schlechthin
Ähm
Davon von
Der bank wo ich arbeite
Das einsatzzenter quasi unter
Besucht bei uns auf der arbeit
Das ist ja da wo ich dabei sitze
Ich sitz ja mittlerweile
Nicht mehr direkt bei dem team
Wo ich dazu gehöre sondern dort wo auch unser
Support sitzt
Äh in der nähe
Und da kam quasi an einem tag hat sich
Der oberchef angekündigt
Der wollte ein paar anderen oberchefs
Die nicht ganz so oberchefig wie er sind
Wollte mal die einsatzzentrale zeigen
Und ähm
Natürlich hat sich das
Im vorfeld
Das ist ein riesen aufriss wenn der kommt
Mit bodyguards und vorher
Äh teilweise gebäude durchsuchen und sowas
Da gehts richtig ab ja
Also denen geht teilweise auch richtig der stift
Dass da irgendwas irgendwas ist
Wenn der halt bodyguards in die eigene firma mitbringst
Beziehungsweise in das wo du der chef bist
Dann würde ich mir ein paar gedanken machen
Aber okay das ist ein anderes thema
Also da gehts richtig ab
So mit gebäude untersuchen bodyguards am start
Und alle möglichen zeug
Naja zumindest
Der ist da angerückt mit
Noch ein paar anderen chefs
Aber diesmal halt hauptsächlich
Vom außendienst
Also sprich quasi
Mit den außendienstleuten
Die besonders viel verkaufen um es mal auf den punkt zu bringen
Beziehungsweise die möglichst viele
Leute
Haben die sachen für sie verkaufen
Mit denen ist er da angerückt
Und natürlich im vorfeld wurde das bei uns auch angekündigt
Der kommt da vorbei
Und erstmal
Mussten wir natürlich dafür sorgen
Das das ein bisschen diverser aussieht
Also sprich haben sie noch zwei mädels dabei gesetzt
Die da normalerweise überhaupt nicht am start sind
Aber gut
Zumindest
Genau siriusmax dann habe ich das schon mal erzählt
Zumindest haben sie noch ein paar mehr leute dabei gesetzt
Das es halt ein bisschen wichtiger aussieht
Und wir haben uns im vorfeld überlegt
Alter was machen wir wenn der jetzt kommt
Wir müssen ja irgendwie
Sollen wir ein bisschen
Beschäftigt faken
Und da meinte halt dann der chef der da war
Meinte jaja also auf jedenfall
Wir müssen doch ein bisschen so tun
Als machen wir gerade was richtig wichtiges
Also haben wir uns dann zusammen
An den rechner gesetzt
Quasi ein kollege von mir und mich
Der neben mich an dem platz
Ich halt auf die andere seite
Und wir haben uns halt überlegt
Wenn der jetzt rein kommt
Dann machen wir halt so ein
Wie auf so einem werbebild
Weiß nicht
Es gibt so nur noch 15 werbung
Business
Business werbung
Ja
So in der richtung haben wir dann da gemacht
Also ich hab bei ihm auf monitor
habe so gemacht so hmmm
Und er hat dann halt irgendwas getippt
Und ja so ungefähr
So ungefähr haben wir dann da gesesst
Naja und
Hat das auch recht clever gemacht
Der hat 22 terminals aufgemacht
22 terminals aufgemacht
Das ist класс der ssh
Falls das jemand kennt
Also sprich der hat sich auf
auf, ähm, ja, genau, genau so
sieht das aus, Leute. Halt nicht unter Mac,
sondern hier unter, unter Linux.
Aber so, aber so sieht das aus im
Endeffekt, ja. Cluster ist das da, da hast du
ähm,
ja, super, toll, Mann, also du hast
ganz viele Terminals auf und
du tippst halt an einem Terminal und
es tippt überall das gleiche.
Ey, das kenn ich, das kenn ich.
So, und das sah dann halt
schon geil aus und ich hatte halt einen Browser
mit einem Ticketsystem auf, weil Ticketsystem halt
schon mal nach richtig Big Brain
und Arbeit aussieht.
Und da hab ich bei ihm mal auf den Bildschirm
geguckt, so nachdem er so, oh ja, da
passiert aber grad hier ganz viel wichtige,
wichtige, wichtige Sachen, ja.
Und da kommt er halt bei uns vorbei
und guckt, guckt bei ihm
so auf den Bildschirm und meint so, oh je,
was ist denn hier los?
Da versteh ich eh schon, versteh ich eh
nix von. Und da guckt er
bei mir auf den Bildschirm und meint so, ah, okay,
damit kann ich schon eher was anfangen.
Ähm, da hab ich halt umgeschaltet,
dann auf meinen Terminal, hab ich gesagt, nee, bei mir
sieht's normalerweise auch nicht so aus.
Ähm, und dann hat er auch gemeint, oh je, oh je, was
da alles auf dem Bildschirm los ist.
Da hab ich halt, hab ich halt so gesagt, aus,
aus, in Anführungszeichen, Witz,
ja, hab ich gesagt, nee, also
normalerweise ist das bei uns
ja auch gar nicht so schlimm. Wir haben das jetzt
bloß alles aufgemacht, weil wir gehört haben, dass sie
vorbeikommen. Und dann hat er gemacht,
ha, ha, ha,
und hat sich voll gefreut. Und da hab ich mir so
gedacht, hm, weiß der, dass ich
weiß, dass er weiß, dass wir ihn,
G-Baiten? Oder hat er
einfach nur gelacht, weil er es geglaubt hat?
Ich glaub, der weiß es. Ich glaub, der
weiß es. Der weiß das.
Der, der, der weiß das.
Ha, ha, ha.
Der weiß das.
Die sind, die sind
auch nicht blöd, ja.
Der weiß das.
Und, und, oh,
vier Minuten, Pockers, Leute. Massive.
Es kann beides sein,
ja. Einmal, dass er denkt, ich hab einfach
nur einen Witz gemacht, aber der weiß,
also, das ist ja schon Triple-G-Bait,
ja. Also, dem
ist klar, dass ich das
sage
und so tue, als meine ich
es als Witz, aber er weiß,
dass es in Wirklichkeit so ist
und es ist eigentlich kein Witz.
Also,
also hier, Elevenhead.
Ich glaub, dem ist es klar,
der weiß das. Elevenhead,
ja, genau.
Das sieht so aus, ungefähr dann.
Das ist für ein Big-Brain-Libby,
nicht mehr reicht.
Es ist eh, ich muss es mir ehrlich sagen,
es ist eh teilweise
viel einfacher
und unproblematischer,
wenn man sagt, wie es ist.
Das hätte ich früher auch nicht gedacht,
ja.
Also,
man neigt ja immer dazu,
wenn man gefragt wird, und, wie weit ist das
jetzt und was ist da und wie läuft's da
und so. Man neigt ja irgendwie so instinktiv
dazu, sich da so ein bisschen was,
die Sachen ein bisschen schöner auszuschmücken, als,
als sie eigentlich, als sie eigentlich
sind, ja.
Aber,
oftmals fährst du
einfacher, wenn, je nachdem,
natürlich muss man gucken, ja.
Man kann jetzt, das geht auch nicht bei jedem
und das geht auch nicht bei allem mit jedem, ja.
Aber oftmals fährt man
wirklich einfacher, wenn es halt auch,
vor allem, wenn man jemand hat, der halt auch wirklich
hören will, was Sache ist, wenn man einfach
erzählt, wie es ist, ja.
Wenn ich einer, wenn, wenn,
beispielsweise, wenn mich mein Chef,
ja, fragt, okay, äh, Max, wie, wie weit bist du mit
diesem Ticket gekommen?
Da sag ich, äh, und ich sag ihm dann, äh,
äh, so nach dem Motto, ja, ich bin gerade dabei,
äh, zu evaluieren, was es hier für Lösungen
gibt und ich bin da gerade dran am Thema,
wir, wir verfolgen das Ganze aktiv, äh,
aktiv weiter und auch in Zusammenarbeit
mit unserem Support schauen wir, dass das,
dass das, dass das vorwärts geht und
dann müssen wir schauen, dass die extern, bla bla bla bla.
Es ist eigentlich kompletter Schwachsinn, ja.
Weil den interessiert ja wirklich, wie es ist,
wenn ich ihm einfach sage, hier, ähm,
ich hab mir das mal angeguckt
und
was sie da haben wollen, ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Deswegen hab ich noch nichts gemacht.
Und ich hab schon 20 Mal versucht,
rauszubekommen, was die wollen und es kann
mir keiner erklären. Und dann sagt er,
ja gut, dann machen wir das Ticket zu.
Das ist viel einfacher, als
da im Kreis rumzureden.
Wie gesagt, man muss
gucken, mit wem man das macht. Also ich würde das
jetzt nicht unbedingt, äh, mit eurem,
äh, mit eurem Chef, mit eurem
Abteilungsleiter oder irgendwie anderen Leuten
machen.
Wenn ihr nicht genau wisst, was derjenige von
euch will, ja.
Es hat seinen Grund, dass Leute Geld bekommen
für, äh, Sachen schön umschreiben.
Ja, meinem Chef ist das auch alles egal.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache Ticketbearbeitungszeiten
sind niedrig. Für die Sachen, wo wir Tickets haben.
Zappcon sagt, du hast einen guten Chef, wenn er so reagiert.
Ja, ich muss sagen, wir haben ja erst, der hat ja erst
gewechselt. Also sprich, äh, den,
den wir jetzt haben, der ist ja erst seit
zwei Jahren oder so.
An der Position. Vorher hat er ja auch was, was
mit Technik gemacht.
Und ich muss sagen, da gibt's nicht wirklich Mühe.
Und ich glaube, dass der, ähm,
was so Arbeitsverteilung und
Sachen machen, dass der da eine ähnliche,
eine ähnliche Einstellung hat, ähm,
wie ich.
So nach dem Motto, man muss nicht möglichst
viel und,
also man muss nicht möglichst viel machen,
man muss nicht möglichst, ähm,
überall mitmischen oder sonst was.
Man muss die wichtigen Sachen machen, die, äh,
Werbung machen für das Team.
Beziehungsweise für die jeweilige Person
oder, ähm,
ähm, Sachen, die man macht, ist es besser,
wenn die funktionieren und nicht im Nachhinein
irgendwelche Probleme machen.
Man muss die, man muss einfach die richtigen
Sachen machen.
Und der will auch nicht.
Der hat genau das gleiche Interesse, wenn ich
was bastel, was, ähm, weil, weil ich, weil ich,
keine Ahnung, keinen Bock hab, weil ich faul bin
und ich das so bastel, dass es funktioniert am
Ende, ähm, mach ich das ja auch nicht, äh, aus
reiner Nächstenliebe, sondern weil ich mich
selbst nicht in Zukunft mehr damit beschäftigen will.
Und ich glaube, dass der, der hat da einen
ähnlichen Ansatz und die richtigen Sachen auch
zu Ende machen.
Ja, das, das kriegen wir nicht hin, aber das ist
so ein Problem in der, von der ganzen Firma, dass
die Sachen oftmals nicht fertig gemacht werden.
Ja, also wie viel unfertige Containerprojekte und
Virtualisierungsprojekte und Cloud-Geschichten wir
da teilweise parallel haben, da blickt kein Mensch
mehr durch.
Ja, aber das muss ich sagen, wie gesagt, da, wir,
wir haben, also ich hab den aktuellen Chef erst seit
zwei Jahren ungefähr und er gibt sich erstens,
gibt er sich wirklich Mühe, aber halt auch in den
richtigen, ähm,
in den richtigen Bereichen.
Also ich, ich find so, also bei dem, bei, bei dem
Alten hab ich total oft über irgendwelche Sachen
diskutieren müssen, ja.
Ähm, und mein alter Chef, der hat auch immer so
komische, so komische Tricks versucht.
Zum Beispiel, so ein, ein schöner Trick, dem, was
mein alter Chef immer funktioniert hat, wo du das
Gefühl hast, dass er dich eigentlich verarschen will
und jebaiten will, anstatt irgendwie, dass da was
Sinnvolles rauskommt.
Ähm.
Also, wenn du dem, wenn du, wenn du gesagt hättest,
äh, also beim alten Chef wohlgemerkt, ja, also wenn
du dem gesagt hast, hier, also, ähm, ich muss mir jetzt
bei irgendeinem Thema ausdenken, keine Ahnung, wenn
du dem gesagt hast, ähm, also fünf Server werden an
der Stelle wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich nicht
reichen, ähm, aber, ähm, die Leute, die die Anwendung
entwickelt haben, sagen, mehr als fünf Server
parallel sind nicht supported und, äh, ja, ich wollte,
wollte das mal sagen, dass das halt so nicht
funktionieren wird.
So.
Dann dauert's ein halbes Jahr und das Ding fährt gegen
die Wand, weil man mit fünf Server nicht auskommt.
So, und, ähm, mein alter Chef hätte dann zum Beispiel
den Trick versucht, so nach dem Motto, Max, warum hast
du mir denn nicht, äh, wie, wie konnte das, wie konnte
das denn in die Hose gehen, ähm, warum, warum funktioniert
das nicht richtig und, äh, wie, wie, was ist hier überhaupt
los?
Er sagt, ja, weil das nur fünf Server, äh, funktioniert,
das ist nur fünf Server nicht ausreichend dafür, hab ich
doch gesagt.
Und dann hätte mein alter Chef gesagt, als, als Ausrede, dass er nicht
dran schuld ist, da hättest du mich jetzt aber energischer
darauf hinweisen müssen, das ist ein Zitat, Alter, das ist ein Zitat, du hättest mich
energischer darauf hinweisen müssen, also total, totaler Schwachsinn,
Alter.
Ich hab mit meinem, ich hab echt mit meinem alten Chef öfters, äh, äh, mich rumstreiten
müssen wegen sowas.
Kobol.
Oh ja, Kobol.
Ja.
Ja, Kobol haben wir auch.
Aber was für eine Aussage, Alter, da hättest du mich entschiedener oder
energischer darauf hinweisen müssen.
Ich kann ja nicht jeden Tag da auf der Matte stehen und irgendwas sagen, das muss er sich
halt merken.
So, und das ist mit meinem neuen Chef, ist das viel, viel besser, der koordiniert die
Sachen besser, ähm, der sucht sich die richtigen Themen aus, der verkauft die richtigen Sachen
auch, äh, dementsprechend in, in die Welt hinaus, so quasi, dass es halt auch nach,
dass es halt auch gut aussieht, was, was die Leute machen, so, so muss das sein, ja, also,
da, da muss ich nie diskutieren, das, das funktioniert nicht, wir sind uns da eigentlich
zu 90 Prozent einig und da hätte ich echt keinen Bock drauf, ich war ja, ihr könnt
euch ja noch dran erinnern, vor ein paar Jahren im Stream, wo ich nicht ganz, ähm, ohne Hintergedanken
Stellenanzeigen mir angeguckt hab, weil da hab ich ja auch gesagt, also, lange mach ich
den Scheiß auch nicht mehr, äh, aber wie gesagt, wir, ja, ja, wir haben Kobol, wir
haben, wir haben richtig Big Brain Kobol.
Bei uns ist, bei uns ist Kobol nicht einfach Kobol.
Weil die haben bei uns festgestellt, dass, ähm, wir noch sehr viele alte Software in
Kobol haben, aber keine Leute mehr haben, die richtig Kobol programmieren können und,
ähm, auch, auch eigentlich gar keine richtigen Kobol-Umgebungen mehr haben, wo man das laufen
lassen kann ordentlich, frag mich nicht, was da mit alles zusammenhängt, ja, ähm, und
deswegen haben sie sich was ganz Tolles überlegt, sie haben sich eine Kobol-Runtime oder einen
Kobol-Cross-Runtime.
Irgendwas, irgendwas haben sie sich gekauft, ich weiß nicht, wie es genau funktioniert,
interessiert mich auch nicht, will ich auch gar nichts mit zu tun haben, der Kobol in Java
umwandelt oder aber der, der, eine Kobol-Runtime für Java oder irgendwie so merkwürdige Sachen
haben sie sich gekauft und jetzt läuft quasi das Kobol-Zeug, ähm, mehr oder weniger neben
dem Java-Zeug.
Das ist halt, das ist halt das, das Schlimmste aus beiden Welten dann zusammen, ne.
Ja, das ist das, was wir verwenden.
Das ist das, was sie sich gekauft haben, warte mal, ich zeig's euch mal, ähm, Akku-Kobol.
Akku-Kobol ist ein Dialekt der Programmiersprache Kobol und hier unten steht's, ähm, mit Version
8 wird eine lückenlose Einbindung von Akku-Kobol-GT in Java inklusive der Verwendung von Java-GUIs
ermöglicht.
Alter, MonkaS, ein Eclipse-Plugin gibt's dafür auch, ja, also die, diesen Kram haben
sie sich hier gekauft.
Also sprich, du kannst quasi damit irgendwie...
Irgendwie Kobol in Java laufen lassen oder so, ganz, ganz abgedrehtes Zeug, hab ich nix
mit zu tun, bin ich auch ganz froh drum, will ich auch nix, echt, will ich wirklich nix
mit zu tun haben.
Es gibt Dialekte in Programmiersprachen, ja, fast jede C++-Implementierung ist ein eigener
Dialekt, weil die unterschiedliche Dinger haben.
Zwei Minuten, Poggers, also ich bin eigentlich schon viel länger on, als ich on sein wollte,
ne.
Aber das wird nicht fertig, der Scheiß hier.
What the fuck?
Hast du Kurzarbeit?
Nee.
Aber nicht, ähm, der Vorteil bei uns ist, dass unser Außendienst anscheinend in allen
möglichen Lebenslagen den Leuten Sachen verkaufen kann und dementsprechend läuft das eigentlich
ganz gut.
Magst du, wie wär's, wenn du immer so spät streamst?
Äh, ich hab keinen, ich hab ja keinen Streamplan, ich, ich, ich stream immer, wenn's, wie's
gerade passt.
Also ich kann das im Vorfeld nicht näher eingrenzen.
Was?
Was ist das?
Achso, so'n Ding haben wir auch.
Nee.
So'n Ding haben wir nicht.
Wir haben irgendeinen Z, Z-Series-Host oder so.
Oder ist das so was?
Jaja, so'n, so'n, so'n alles, oder hatten wir, hatten wir, stimmt, stimmt's gar nicht
in der Form, das hatten wir mal.
Wir haben jetzt irgendwas, irgendwas Neueres.
Soja, so'n, so'n fettes Ding, da ist, Kobol ist angesagt, ja, und übrigens die IBM-Lizenz,
Lizenzierungsvarianten sind da.
Ja.
Das ist, das ist ja auch geil.
Du bezahlst nicht die Hardware, sondern du bezahlst die CPU-Zeit auf deiner eigenen Hardware
in deinem eigenen Rechenzentrum.
Das ist mal Big Brain, oder?
Also du kaufst dir die Hardware, hast's in deinem Rechenzentrum stehen, aber du musst
trotzdem die Rechenzeit bezahlen.
Also quasi Cloud-Abrechnungsmodell für Inhouse im eigenen Z-Hardware.
Das ist IBM-Logik.
Michael, du musst doch, du musst, du musst doch sagen, du musst doch Sachen, du musst
Also, das ist ein bisschen übertrieben, sie den Wecker zu stellen.
Kannst du doch einfach, entweder guckst du dir die Worts später an,
oder was, bis ich mal abends online bin.
Ich würde dafür jetzt nicht irgendwie Schlaf-Sacrificen quasi,
dass du mein blödes Gelaber hier mit anhören kannst.
Aber es ist schön, dass du am Start bist.
Du bist ja schon ziemlich lange dabei.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade was ein.
Du bist kein Sub, komm mal her.
Aber, Abo verschenken.
Du bist schon so lange dabei.
Abo verschenken.
Und zack.
Sollte es eigentlich funktionieren.
Excellent.
Geht.
Nice.
Hat funktioniert.
Michael, 50.000 verlängert sein Geschenk-Abo.
Was?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Schön, dass du schon so lange dabei bist.
So, ist damit jetzt fertig.
Alter Apple.
Wie lang, das ist 40 Minuten am Start.
Ist das Microsoft-Logik oder was?
Gleich geht der Progress-Balken noch rückwärts.
Was passiert denn jetzt eigentlich?
Michael, was passiert jetzt, wenn du das Abo verlängert hast,
und ich hab den Abo geschenkt?
Hast du dann für nächsten Monat automatisch eins?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Fehler in der Matrix, genau.
Ah.
Zwei Monate.
Also das ist so langsam, wie gesagt, ich muss halt morgen wieder arbeiten.
Gut, ich mein, ich kann Home-Office machen, das heißt, ich kann ein bisschen länger schlafen,
aber ich muss jetzt trotzdem langsam mal irgendwann demnächst ins Bett.
Ja, Kobold hatten wir schon.
Dein alter Chef war nicht deine Wiener.
Nee, der alte nicht, der neue.
Was ich da auch ganz gut finde, ich kenne meinen aktuellen Chef jetzt ja auch schon relativ lang.
Wir haben die Ausbildung in der Klasse.
Ich glaube, er hat eine gleiche Firma gemacht.
Der, der müsste auch umgehen.
Ich glaube, der ist, der ist auch nur drei Jahre älter als ich oder so.
Windows Sandbox, können wir das nächstes Mal machen?
Unreal Engine 5 sieht mega nice aus.
Hast du meinen Retweet gesehen?
Nee.
Was wollte ich mir als Stream-Idee jetzt gerade aufschreiben?
Sandbox.
Windows Sandbox.
FreeNAS oder Ubuntu als NAS-Betriebssystem?
Ubuntu.
Wenn du noch mehr machen willst, nimm Ubuntu.
FreeNAS ist halt eine NAS.
Ohne irgendwas.
Wenn du ein bisschen mehr machen willst, nimm Ubuntu.
Da hast du wenigstens die, hast du wenigstens die Auswahl.
Wenn du natürlich ein nett, wenn du, wenn du ein hübsches GUI haben willst,
dann ist FreeNAS sicherlich nicht verkehrt.
Also wenn dir ein Web-GUI wichtig ist, dann nimm FreeNAS.
Aber ich bin kein großer Fan von FreeNAS.
Erstens ist die Community irgendwie ziemlich, ähm,
wie beschreibe ich das am besten?
Und, ähm,
die sich dann teilweise weigern, den Leuten zu helfen,
nur weil sie kein ECC-RAM haben.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben, die FreeNAS-Community.
So nach dem Motto, wie du willst denn NAS betreiben,
ohne mindestens 48 Gigabyte ECC-RAM?
Da gibt's keinen Support für.
Was ein Schwachsinn.
Welcher Heimanwender braucht, selbst für ZFS, 48G RAM
und ECC, totaler Schwachsinn.
Man kann ZFS ohne Probleme, ohne ECC-RAM betreiben.
Das wird dadurch nicht unsicherer.
Es wird auch nicht sicherer, ja, aber es wird nicht unsicherer
wie ein normales Dateisystem.
Das ist auch so eine Sache, wo ich mir immer denke,
man übertreibt es mal nicht.
Äh, wo ist denn der Vorteil von ECC-RAM?
Also, oh, ich habe schon wieder irgendjemand timeoutet.
Meine Fresse, ey.
Kann man das nicht rückgängig machen?
Ich habe, ich habe Kyokun getimeoutet, Alter.
Wie macht man das rückgängig?
Untimeout.
Okay.
Also, was auch immer, ähm, ich muss diese komischen Mod-Tools ausschalten, Chat.
Ich muss mal die Mod-Tools ausschalten, das ist wirklich eklig.
Kyokun, bist du wieder da?
Funktioniert wieder alles.
Ja, vielleicht musst du refreshen.
Okay.
Kannst du ZEV erklären?
Nee.
Ich habe übrigens den Chat jetzt gelöscht.
Ich sehe jetzt nicht mehr, was die Leute gefragt haben.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Was, ich habe Kyokun gekillt?
Wie?
Stimmt, warst du nicht mal Mod?
Ah, jetzt aber.
Jetzt geht es wieder.
Welchen Mikro-Tick-Router hast du empfohlen?
Hex-POE.
Okay, Leute, ich muss jetzt auf.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit...
Wisst ihr, was wir machen?
Wir machen hier einfach Suspend und machen das nächste Mal weiter.
Und lassen das nächste Mal weiterlaufen.
In der Hoffnung, es geht dann weiter.
Ähm, ich kann jetzt nicht länger on bleiben, sonst...
Oh.
Ah, ich habe zu wenig Speicher.
Was?
Free and additional 303 MB.
Weißt du was?
Leck mich fertig.
Leck mich Microsoft, leck mich Apple.
Piss dich, Alde.
Fertig, äh...
Kack da.
Wow, MonkaS, warum dauert das so lang?
Okay, war komplett umsonst, Chat.
Ich habe es mir besser vorgestellt.
Wer konnte ahnen, dass der Kram eine Stunde braucht, anstatt 10 Minuten?
Morgen nochmal an...
Ich mache es morgen vielleicht einfach mal an, wenn ich den Rechner anmache, ob es dann fertig ist.
Ich lasse es morgen einfach mal so laufen.
Also, ich mache mal Schluss, ne?
Also, bis, ähm...
Wartet mal.
Ähm, also.
Macht's gut, wir sehen uns nächstes Mal.
Bis dann, CU.
Ach so, Outro.
Outro brauchen wir noch.
Macht's gut.
Outro